Hello Ladies and gentlemen.
Anytime you use that word,
anytime you say,
Ladies and gentlemen,
you're either joking around or you're being a big phony,
right?
Ladies and Gentlemen,
trying to be nice.
Uh,
this episode of the podcast is brought to you by ting.
Ting is a mobile service company,
a mobile cell phone company.
How would you say that it's not mobile anymore?
Remember I used to call them these,
call them car phones.
Remember those days?
Steve Maxwell,
you remember this?
I remember that they were caught.
I just got a car phone.
Look,
he's got a car phone in his pocket.
This guy's crazy.
That was Greg is your arm man.
They used to be car phones.
They were car phones before their mobile phones.
Ting has it set up so that you pay for what you use.
What they do is they take the ting buys time on the sprint backbone,
so you get the exact same service you'd get with a major carrier like sprint,
but they do it their own way with their own rates and their own deal.
And their deal is they don't have any like,
oh you,
you get a hundred minutes a month or 200 minutes a month.
You just pay for what you use.
And in that method,
you'd be surprised.
98% of people would save money with tank.
They have no early termination fees and no contracts.
So they cut all that nonsense out and I honestly think that that's going to be
the future.
I think that all that stuff about contracts and it's a scam and they rope you in
and they rope you in and they get you in debt.
Like when you buy a phone from a normal carrier.
So if you buy an iPhone and you,
you know,
you sign up for a two year contract and buy an iPhone,
you're not really buying that phone.
You're buying a piece of that phone and then the rest of it,
you're paying off over a long period of time.
That's why when you want to leave,
they hit you with this big cancellation fee.
Ting says,
you know what?
Fuck all that.
Let's just cancel all that nonsense.
Let's stop doing that.
Sell people the phones for what the phones worth,
sell it to them at a reasonable rate and give them very reasonable rates for
their service itself.
98% of people would save money with tank.
That's pretty crazy.
$21 the average monthly bill per term per device for 10 customers.
I know almost everybody pays more than 21 bucks a month for cell phone coverage.
And again,
you're using the best android phones available.
You can also bring over iPhones from sprint and they have excellent service,
excellent phones to these.
Android phones are fantastic.
They have the ht one,
HTC one,
they have the LG phones,
they have the Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is the one that I have.
They have the the galaxy s five all these killer phones and a killer rate and he
can't go wrong with it.
And if you use rogan.ting.com that is the website.
Go there.
You will save $25 off your first device from Tang.
So that's rogan.ting.com go there and save money and,
and be a part of an ethical company.
And that's one of the things that I really appreciate about Ting.
They'd done all this on their own.
They also at their two year anniversary,
they slash their rates and they did it without,
I mean they,
they didn't have any motivation to do it other than,
you know what,
we can do this,
we can offer people a great deal,
give them a cheaper deal and a great deal for people that are power users.
If you're one of those freaks,
it's constantly downloading things and downloading apps and mp3s and alike.
You can save a shit load of money on tank.
And uh,
the,
the phone that we use now for the podcast is a,
a tank phone.
So,
uh,
the,
the actual office phone is a tank phone.
So there Papao rogan.ting.com we're also brought to you by on it.
That's o n n I t,
a human optimization website.
We have a new color battle rope in the commercial.
Look at that.
It's very exciting,
Jamie.
Now it's red and black.
It's fine.
It looks like it's business like you're serious.
That's the,
the 50 foot 2.5 inch battle rope.
Um,
we sell strength and conditioning equipment.
We also sell the,
it's essentially by calling yourself a human optimization website.
We didn't even really have another name for it.
Like what is on itself?
Well,
we sell a bunch of cool shit.
What we sell is all stuff that I use as far as fitness equipment.
We sell things like weight vest,
ab wheels,
kettlebells,
steel maces steel clubs,
we sell medicine balls,
jump ropes,
we saw,
so basically all the tools that you would use to develop functional strength.
And then on top of that,
we sell really healthy foods like the new warrior bar,
which is a,
uh,
a buffalo bar,
organic buffalo meat.
It's all organic.
It's all with,
uh,
with,
no preservatives.
It doesn't have any artificial flavors,
it doesn't have any artificial colors.
And we had the made by the same company that makes those a tonka bars.
So what they're done is they're done in this ancient Lakota tradition of
preserving buffalo meat with cranberries,
no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
no nitrates.
You really,
it's really a guilt free.
And it's also got 14 grams of protein and 140 calories and uh,
only four grams of fat.
Really healthy for you.
No MSG,
no soy,
no nothing.
And uh,
it's one of the things that we started carrying exclusively at on it.
They're actually made for on it.
And we tried to do that as often as possible.
Things like the hemp forest protein bars,
we have the main,
uh,
we use the finest hamp that we can get from Canada,
which a big lawsuit right now in Kentucky and Kentucky.
They,
uh,
they're suing the federal government suing the DEA because the DEA confiscated
hemp seeds.
Non-Psychoactive hemp seeds.
Why did they confiscate them?
Because they're in cahoots,
ladies and gentlemen,
Coats with other businesses.
It has nothing to do with protecting the children from hemp hemp.
It's good for you.
Hams healthy.
It's an excellent source of protein.
It's also completely free of THC.
A lot of people worry,
hey,
if I take your hand for us,
I,
you know,
I work at ups and they test me.
You're not going to test positive.
You will not.
There's zero THC in hemp.
All it is is a super healthy plant that gets demonized because a bunch of old
people are scared of marijuana or people are making money off the fact that
marijuana is illegal.
That's more more likely the case than not in 2014 but times they are changing.
Anyway,
go to ana.com o.
N N.
I t used the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any of the supplements,
all of the supplements,
whether it's Alpha,
brain,
shroom tech,
sport,
new mood,
Steve Max was old school.
He doesn't take any supplements.
All the supplements come with a 30 pill,
90 day,
100% money back guarantee.
This is all stuff that I use.
It's all stuff that Aubrey uses is all stuff that we have found to be either
beneficial either in clinical trials.
We did a double blind placebo test of Alpha brain with positive results.
All the results are posted on [inaudible] dot com along with the references for
all the individual ingredients that are in Alpha brain,
shroom tech,
and new mood.
All of it's explained,
but again,
a hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product to say this stuff sucks and you get
your money back.
All right.
We don't expect that because we're selling you the best shit we could possibly
find.
That's it.
Boom.
Cuban music.
Young Jamie.
Steve Maxwell was here.
Use the codeword Rogan had on it.
Save yourself some money.
Experience.
Hey Joe Rogan podcast.
Steve Maxwell,
my friend.
Good to see you man.
Last time.
If you see ladies and gentlemen,
I'm sitting here and a chair with no back note.
My perfect posture.
I just received this,
uh,
this,
what do they call these things?
Ergonomic besides gay.
Don't say gay because a lot of people would call it a chair.
The essays,
the position that the Samurai position.
Yeah.
It was just supposed to like promote good posture because I always find myself
leaning in these chairs,
like cracking and trying to find a,
so this is a,
it makes you actively keep your back in a straight line.
Right?
Is that the idea behind this?
The idea that you know,
the chair is like the new cigarettes these days.
Yes.
That's what they say.
Sitting is the new smoking.
Then the new smoking.
So many people when they stating if you have like bad posture and you're sitting
your chair,
you really are putting tremendous stress on just a few of the,
the,
the uh,
parts of your spine,
like a few of the discs and those discs oftentimes can rupture.
They say that people get herniated disc from wearing a wallet.
If you have a wallet in your pocket,
like say if you're a cab driver or something and you sit down all the time on a
wallet,
like you can get a herniated disc from that.
Well,
I was think of that.
I don't even pressure.
Imagine your hip like totally.
I imagine that like wearing a shoe right with one heel higher than the other,
right.
Well sort of the same,
same idea where you're sitting with one part of your hip above the other for
years and of course it's going to,
you know,
the stress of just being so imbalanced,
it's going to take its toll on your body.
It's interesting because most folks would never think that that could be
possible.
You would,
you would just think,
well,
it's not hurting.
Your body's fine.
Like it's not going to get injured,
but your body's kind of like,
it's all pliable and stuff.
Like someone tried to explain to me that everyone has like sort of a boundary on
how flexible they can be.
And I was listening to this guy talk about this.
Well,
you know,
so he was kind of like dismissing some plug,
cause I was,
I'm flexible.
It was like some folks just aren't that flexible,
you know,
you just happened to be naturally flexible.
I'm like,
man,
I don't know about all that.
I really don't think I'm naturally flexible.
I just went through a lot of pain.
Like I forced myself to,
to stretch in really painful positions for,
you know,
30 seconds at a time,
rest for a minute,
30 seconds at a time.
Britain,
when I'm down there for those 30 seconds,
that's hard to breathe.
You're,
you're experiencing pain.
It's that fucking,
a lot of people just aren't willing to do that,
you know?
But that's just a,
another,
uh,
just another example of how the body's kind of pliable.
It's pretty pliable.
I mean,
you couldn't have like a lot of these,
uh,
body real alignment techniques that worked so well like after released tech
Dick.
Uh,
I'm most familiar with rolfing.
Have you ever heard of this?
Yeah,
we talked about last time were here.
I mean that it saved me,
I can't tell you that horrific injuries that rolfing helped me get over,
uh,
you know,
from both wrestling,
Jiu Jitsu and so forth.
So if the,
if the,
the body is very malleable,
very,
very pliable and it can be,
can be moved if a person knows if the practitioner knows how to do it.
Yeah.
I went to a rolfing at the suggestion,
one of the guys from my Jujitsu class who had a bulging disc and dealt with it
with rolfing and uh,
he went to this guy,
but
the guy was really wacky or they can be a little strange.
Some of these bodywork types,
you know,
this guy was very wacky.
He also believed that Bruce Lee could kill people with one punch.
And he was,
he kept telling me this,
that,
you know,
proof you could kill people with just one punch.
He just,
especially if it was a three year old kid or yeah,
it was like fucking,
you know,
a baby or something,
you could probably kill them
one punch.
Like the people have died with one punch,
but it's not normal.
You know,
when a guy kills the guy with one punch,
like this idea that he's got like a gun in his hand,
I need you to just shoot people.
So this guy was [inaudible],
it was a little
wacky and he had some,
uh,
very interesting ideas about what he was doing.
He would push down your ribs and think it would release your neck.
And I wasn't exactly sure if there was a lot of logic to that,
Joe.
You know,
cause if the way the connected tissue spirals through the body,
how does that work?
Like it?
Well,
there's a,
have you ever seen,
what do they call that?
The uh,
the plasticized man that uh,
that exhibit where the body works,
the body works amazing.
You ever see the fashion part of that and how the guy ever figured out the
chemicals to use does dissolve away all other tissues and leave.
The one in tech that he wanted is just mindblowing.
But anyway,
it's just like a,
it looks like DNA strands all spiraled up.
So really,
truly your ankle bone is connected to your neck and
one part of your body is out of alignment.
Right?
Or,
or you know,
a stressor in mobilized.
It can cause some problems in other areas of the body.
Well this guy would like push down on your ribs with his elbows,
like to loosen up things in your back.
Unbelievably painful.
Just digging your world,
you know,
his,
his elbow into your ribs and moving things around.
And then you'd have you stand up and he'd look at,
you see if you're leaning to the laughter and leaning to the right and where
your posture is.
I don't know about all that,
but when he got down to business on your back and would,
you know,
break it,
would you want to tap out?
I mean,
it's really bad.
It,
it's pretty,
it was pretty bad.
But boy,
when you leave it's like everything is just kinda moving better and you feel
taller.
Yeah.
Well you feel,
I didn't ever feel tall.
I'm short.
So are you pal?
But I'm pretty sure.
But I definitely felt looser.
I felt like more relieved and I,
I think that there's a lot of folks that go out there and they,
you know,
they hit the gym,
they lift weights,
they'll do Jujitsu,
do all these different things,
but they never get massaged.
And uh,
I think they're doing themselves a huge disservice.
You know,
I've,
I've said that to many,
many a Jujitsu guys.
Like if you can just at least once a week,
just go,
go to one of those time massages and have one of those people work on you.
Or if you can go to a real good sports medicine place and have someone do some
deep tissue on you,
it makes a world of difference.
Well,
I mean,
think about the nature of the sport,
right?
You're basically trying to hurt each other as much as possible.
Yeah.
You're trying to deflect as much pain and or choke to got asleep.
So I mean for sure it takes a toll on the body and you have to do these things
in order to keep yourself in alignment because there's just no way you can do a
heavy combat sports like that without suffering.
So you're going to definitely get knocked out of alignment.
Uh,
have things move that shouldn't be moved and you need someone to kind of put
them back in place.
And a lot of times you can't do it on your own.
Yeah.
I mean the foam rolling and a lot of times mobility exercises work pretty good
for that,
uh,
self treatment.
But usually after a couple of days and that stuff isn't working,
that's when you know,
it's time to get a therapist to actually put stuff back and place.
Boy,
do you ever,
uh,
work with,
um,
lacrosse balls?
Do you ever do any of that?
I have.
Yeah.
It's great.
Lie on your back and then put the Lacrosse ball under your back and roll,
like bridge on the Lacrosse Ball.
Oh,
sure.
And also there's ways you can put the ball against the wall and like we're all
into your shoulders and your packs so forth and really release a lot of stuff.
But sometimes that just doesn't work and that's when you know,
it's time to get to the,
uh,
to the therapist.
Yeah.
It's one of the things that I'm finding out through this last year because this
last year has been the year of this back injury that I had,
which is way better now.
I mean now I'm,
I'm lifting heavy kettlebells and doing all this different things.
No problem,
no pain during the day.
And um,
you know,
we've been doing this for like 10 minutes,
this new chair.
But I think this might help me too.
But the,
um,
what I'm learning is how many people
get injured and then don't take care of it.
They just keep working.
They keep training that she could try to work around it and it winds up getting
really bad or I ignore it.
Yeah.
And crazy isn't it?
It is very crazy cause I'm running into a series of these guys once I started
opening up about this,
whether it's from the underground guys that I know on Twitter or guys that I
know from Jujitsu class who now have atrophy.
And um,
according to the doctor that,
uh,
administers that Regena keen,
that blood spinning procedure that I had done to reduce inflammation.
He says once you have atrophy,
like that's really bad.
He's like the,
a lot of people think they're going to have atrophy and they got to put it off
and put it off.
It's like if you have that for more than like,
you know,
x amount of months,
a lot of times those nerves never get fully,
never return 100%.
He said that there's surgery that they have to do to open up the pathways to
alleviate the pressure on those nerves.
And if that doesn't happen,
if you don't do that,
like you,
you run the chance of having permanent atrophy of your muscles and have
permanent loss of function of a,
of your limbs.
Well blows my mind how people just don't pay attention to their body.
Like pain is a signal that something's wrong myself,
that's definitely wrong.
And to ignore it and just keep pushing and driving through.
And of course,
you know,
uh,
MMA guys,
Jujitsu guys,
wrestlers,
a grid,
iron football,
rugby guys,
they're pretty tough guys.
And a lot of times they just are very stoic and love doing what they do and just
don't want to stop and we'll just continue to drive themselves,
you know,
long after they should instead of just taking care of it.
Yeah.
And you got to know when a tap out,
you also got to know that if you don't,
there's guys that like let themselves get injured,
you know,
they'd allow,
I'm not topping,
you know,
if you tap you,
you learn the same mistake than not tapping.
Okay.
The mistake is the guy yourself into a bad position.
Something went wrong,
you got your arm caught,
you either didn't respect the person or the person was better than you and they
set you up and they got you and they go and they got you.
And that's it.
You've got got and there's a certain point where you have to realize you got God
and you've got to tap.
Cause if you don't tap and you get your elbow snapped a,
it might not ever be the same again and B,
you're going to be out for a long time.
Well it's one thing if you're in the world championships,
right?
Yeah.
And you know,
you're a black belt and you're,
you know,
you're a fighter.
That's what you do.
Or you're in an MMA event,
you know,
on,
like John Jones versus via.
Exactly.
Okay.
So you might raise risk getting your elbows snap,
but for the average guy in the gym,
or even just like a local tournament,
come on man,
once you're actually caught the,
the techniques already there,
you already made the mistake.
So acknowledge the mistake tap app and forget about it.
Just like,
you know,
it'd be,
it'd be like being thrown out into softball game or whatever.
Right?
But guys,
they put too much emphasis on,
uh,
never getting caught or I can't get caught or whatever.
But to get out of whatever hold you've been caught in it just zoos strength.
It's,
it has nothing to do with technique,
you know,
I mean a good guy,
if he gets here,
you're God.
It's an interesting thing isn't it?
It's like people don't,
I mean they don't like getting thrown out and softball.
Nobody likes when you hit a fly ball and someone catches it.
But if it's a softball game and everybody's drinking beers and you know,
having Burgers,
it's no big deal.
But if you're on the mat and you're doing jujitsu and someone catches you with
something,
it's,
there's so much pride and machismo involved in that position and that situation.
And if you can get out of it,
you know?
Yeah,
you didn't get me,
you know,
even though your arms all fucked up,
like I have not tapped the things before and got out of it and been okay.
But then my arm is fucked up for months.
You know,
like I had a bad elbow for probably three months because one guard pass I'm
passing and you know,
sometimes he passed.
You leave your arm out a little bit to try to bait the guy to go for a Komora so
you could try to get over the knees and as I'm passing and he locked in the car,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Like this is tight,
God dammit.
And I'm trying to figure out do I tap here or do I keep going,
pop,
you know,
powered out of it.
But then I couldn't do chin up.
Then you suffer for four months,
for months,
for months.
It's like,
you know,
it's like one of those deals where you,
you feel the pain maybe like just a little bit.
But the problem with something like Jujitsu or even wrestling,
sometimes it goes from zero to a hundred and like just a brief blink like heel
hooks.
And then by that point it's already too late.
So you know the risks,
the risk to benefit ratio,
you know,
the,
the idea of,
oh,
I got out of it versus not being able to train for weeks or even months just
never makes it worth it.
And that's one of the big differences as you get older.
You know,
a guy my age in the sixties no way man.
Tap early,
tap often,
rarely smart.
That's,
that's the key to doing Jujitsu for a lifetime.
You just learned,
hey man,
you got me great job.
I don't care if it's a white belt,
whatever.
You got it.
Okay,
I made a mistake.
Yeah.
Oh,
keep playing man.
If you teach them the technique correctly and they get in the right position and
you know your arm is deepen their crotch and they got your thumb up and they're
pulling on it,
that's,
they'd got it.
They got it.
You know?
I mean,
they might not be able to hang onto it because they're not familiar with the
position.
You know,
like if you watch like Rhonda Rousey,
she's the best example I think of someone who knows how to hold an arm bar,
not just keep an arm bar,
not just catching armbar,
but hold it through all of the transitions.
Like,
people can flip over,
they can kick their legs over,
they can try to roll and she just keeps it and she keeps adjusting and she keeps
rolling with it.
She's the best at that.
And that's kind of the difference between like a real legit blackbelt like
Rhonda and someone who's never done it before.
And maybe just learning the technique and maybe you could kind of get out
because if you just turn your arm a little bit and now you know your elbows up
instead of down and there's no pressure on it,
you can kind of,
if you're good,
you can kind of get out of the position.
That sort of is the difference between,
you know,
maybe someone like maybe the difference between a purple belt and a black belt.
The difference,
you know,
white belt in a purple belt,
this is like the ability to hang on longer,
the ability to adjust because one of the beautiful things about Jujitsu is
Jujitsu is like the exact opposite of something that is easy and predictable.
And,
uh,
like a,
like a nautilus machine,
you know,
like a nautilus machine is like,
you pushed that thing forward.
It's going to go on the same track every time.
But when you're grappling with a person,
even if you know how to execute the technique with,
you know,
the perfect leverage and all that,
people are moving and resisting and it's a little bit different every time and
their foot's in a little different position every time.
And their arms are a little bit different.
And it's,
it's,
it's so interesting in that sense where you're constantly adjusting.
It's like a fingerprint or a snowflake.
Every time you do it,
it's just a little bit different.
Tell you a funny story as some of your listeners know,
I had the first Jujitsu Academy and the eastern seaboard and these coasts and,
um,
exercise mattresses.
And,
um,
at one point,
we had a guy by the name of Jeff,
Tom Watson,
who was a Philadelphia Eagle football player.
This guy was probably about six foot five to 75 at the time,
if I remember correctly.
Unbelievably strong and lean and slim.
He was the darling of,
uh,
the super bowl the year that the,
the eagles went to the Superbowl in Jacksonville.
He was called up.
He had actually been released from the team,
but they had a couple injuries and they called him in and went in there and
caught a couple of touchdown passes.
Wow.
So,
uh,
he,
he's,
he comes to my Jujitsu class and it's like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
Jujitsu was designed to protect us for guys like you,
man.
You know,
what do you do with a guy?
I mean,
just ungodly strong.
He came to my kettlebell class.
It's the first time I ever had to break out like a 48 kilogram kettlebell just
to teach this guy swings.
Whereas he was based kilogram.
What is that about a hundred pounds?
That's a hundred.
I mean,
he was just like doing front up process with,
you know,
front front raises with his shoulders.
He was just so ridiculously strong.
So he gets a on with one of my brown butter,
the time it fell by the name of Ron [inaudible] who lives in Hawaii.
He teaches in the why now.
But at that time,
Ronnie was a,
uh,
Brown bout and Ron gets them of course,
you know,
and in our block right from the mount and the guy literally does a Turkish getup
with Ronnie,
Bev's him up.
How much does Ronnie way?
Probably about 148 pounds at the time and 50.
And the,
you know,
this guy's like to said he literally does a,
Turkey's got up and was putting Ron's head through the ceiling.
I remember screaming cause I,
you know,
this guy was like really an important part of our team.
Don't hurt,
don't break Rodney,
don't break rati put him down,
put him down.
It was insane.
It's just insane.
Just how strong some people can be,
especially people that are like real super athletes,
like football players,
guys that had been slamming into other 300 pound men for years and hitting sleds
and doing power cleans and just fist all sorts potty.
So designed to just pick up and move heavy things.
And then the average person,
like I remember,
um,
I was at a in Phoenix one night and I don't know who this guy was,
who some pro athlete have no idea who he was,
but he was,
um,
at this gym that I was working out at.
And um,
it was like we were all like little children,
like little children wandering around the gym and this giant showed up.
It wasn't even like a giant amongst men.
I mean,
he was so big.
I dunno,
he was some pro football player,
but he was,
he,
it was so big,
I felt like a tiny child.
Like not like,
well that's a big man and I'm a small man.
Like I'm wasn't even the same species of this guy.
He's probably like six,
seven,
six,
eight,
somewhere around then 370 pounds ish.
Just enormous man.
And you,
you see a person like that and you'd go,
all the self defense stuff is
the window strength and size does matter.
It's that big.
The first time I realized this,
there was a guy that,
uh,
I worked with the first night.
It was Jim and uh,
uh,
the Philadelphia,
it's actually the first one in Pennsylvania and there was a god,
but I think his name is Ron.
She were Rick Chandler.
He played center for the New York jets.
It's the first time I was exposed to an NFL football player and I had just no
idea how unbelievably fast and strong and powerful these guys are.
And of course I was wrestling for the college wrestling team.
It thought it was pretty bad ass and I probably weighed,
I was a lot of heavier back then,
maybe about one 77.
And we get to mess around.
And this guy literally just grabbed me by the ankle and pick me upside down.
I'm not kidding,
I just hold him at arm's length like I was a child and it was just,
whoa.
I just never felt that power and strength,
you know,
my life.
And I mean that's,
you know,
let's,
let's face it,
that's pretty much the elite of the elite,
right?
As far as power athletes go,
we all go to the NFL and there where they can make some money.
The only other thing I would think of would be like those guys that do those
strong man competitions.
Those guys are pretty ridiculous but pretty crazy strong.
If you notice that there's that one guy,
it's not magnus.
What is the guy's name that's been fighting and MMA?
God,
what is his name?
Oh,
the chairman.
No,
he's polling
Sanford.
Oh yeah.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
Damn it.
That was the rationale.
Ski Boots in the House.
Yeah.
Whew.
Guy.
But not doing so well in MMA.
You know,
he got,
he got manhandled by Tim Sylvia.
It was,
it was just a fascinating fight cause Tim Silvia obviously very skilled guy.
I don't know why put Yanoski took that fight.
A lot of people in the Tim Silvia hasn't sort of an awkward uh,
build.
He's a,
he's kind of pigeon toed.
He's enormous guy.
You know,
Tim is,
I think he's like seven or something like
that.
Tim's a very big guy,
but he's also got a lot of extra body fat on him.
And uh,
he could pull the video up.
This is a video of them fighting and you know,
put your mouse key.
Just,
it was just so outclassed.
It was like,
who let you fight a former MMA champion,
a former UFC champion?
Well,
you know,
a lot of the times these guys,
they,
they have a lot of confidence and he,
you know,
he is a real master at his particular sport,
but that's where they make their mistake thinking that somehow that that mastery
in one thing is going to make them better and something else.
And okay,
if I were to fight that guy,
it would be a nightmare for me.
Right.
But when you get against somebody your own size and you're,
uh,
you know,
your,
your own weight,
everything changes for these guys.
Look at him.
And that's,
by the way,
he's lost a lot of weight.
He used to be way bigger when he was just doing strong man stuff because when
he's just doing strongman stuff,
he was just all muscle.
But Tim's a big fucking guy too and Tim is really long and Tim just beat his ass
man.
Plus he has the requisite skills,
you know,
I mean the skill set is everything in a martial art or a combat sport like that.
Yeah,
skill will so often overcome just Robert Straight and raw power.
No,
100% keep playing it.
It's a,
it's,
it's interesting to watch because it puts you,
Nowicki is like so physically strong,
but all that gets countered by the technique of Sylvia.
I mean if these guys were in a weight lifting contest,
you know,
he probably might be able to lift twice as much as Sylvia,
but he rag dogs Tim to the ground.
What does Tim do?
It just the kids back up now I'll put you analyses,
you can start getting tired.
They're exhausted down.
Taking a big guy down all over and over and over and over again like that.
And so disheartening.
If you blow your entire was taking the guy down and then just springs right back
up to his feet.
And a lot of these guys,
they just have no clue.
And just the endurance aspect of this game.
No,
there's nothing like it.
There's less adrenaline dump.
I mean,
imagine if there's like one of his first fights.
He's in front of thousands and thousands of people.
I mean,
do you get that adrenaline dump and it just is so exhausted?
Yeah.
He turned purple like a grape.
As the fight went on,
you start to see it now.
What is that from all the blood is rushing to your skin.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
A lot of times these guys aren't breathing properly right there.
The breath holding and there's a Ma we talked about this last time
visavis sink where the,
there's a partial glottal closure and they're making these grants and their
blood pressure's building up and it,
you know,
that in itself not knowing how to breathe.
Very exhausted.
Awesome.
Yeah,
that was the thing.
One of the things that separated Hickson from a lot of the other Jujitsu guys
was his work with Yoga and you know,
that video choke the,
um,
the DVD choke,
the documentary.
It's fascinating.
Fascinating in a lot of ways,
but really fascinating watching him do that.
Diaphragm thing,
you know,
his son crone was on here and he was explaining the diaphragm
thing and talking about how much emphasis he puts on breathing and in his
training,
charting is supposedly really good for digestion.
It's like an internal massage for your organs and so forth.
Yeah,
it seems like it would be,
uh,
the breath he was using.
It's called breath of fire or a bellows breath.
But it's interesting,
you know,
there's different,
uh,
an aerobatic medicine,
which was the,
the,
uh,
the original medical system in the world.
It's like a 5,000 year old,
uh,
system of medicine.
There's different constitutional types and there's different types of breathing
for each constitutional time.
So for your listeners out there,
not everyone should be doing that particular type of breath set.
It can build up too much heat in,
in certain constitutional types.
Really?
Yeah.
There's 13 different Pranayama breath types and they're all therapeutic.
The breath is like medicine.
If it's applied properly for regaining balance and your body and your system,
there's the Vata,
the Pitta and the coffer and a Hickson's that Kafka and that type of breathing
assessment.
Fantastic for him.
But one piece of good for me,
there's other types of,
oh,
how do you,
how would you know who you,
why you got to study this stuff,
but what it,
what would make you different from him?
Uh,
your constitutional type of set at birth?
Just like,
you know,
you've heard of Ectomorph endomorph sort of a similar classification and there's
different ways that you,
I mean,
if you,
if,
uh,
if you want to actually find out online,
you can Google this and find out what type of constitutional type you are.
And then certain dietary,
uh,
for example,
for me,
uh,
being a pitch,
a very,
uh,
heat,
I produce too much heat,
excess heat,
uh,
eating spicy food for example,
is a horrible thing for a God.
I mean,
really,
what does this based on a aerobatics,
uh,
it was empirical evidence that,
I mean the ancients weren't stupid,
they didn't have our technology,
but they did have the power of observation and these people,
you know,
just imagine how they figured out herbal medicine,
which is around a long time before the pharmaceutical companies.
So what would I Google if I was trying to look this up?
I aerobatic medicine,
they,
U R Y v e d c,
and then look at the Dosha types or d,
o s h a Dosha.
And there's online test that you can take.
One of the first books I ever read was called body,
mind and sport by a guy by the name of John d yard,
who was an American chiropractor and Ira vedic physician and does consultation.
And he had a little test in the book.
There's this back.
Oh,
I dunno.
Probably like 25 years ago I took this test and discover that I indeed was a
pitcher and a,
and how did you discover it?
Like what are the,
there's,
there's this whole line of questions and you're able to find out your type.
But I've also been to a doctor lads,
a clinic in New Mexico in Albuquerque and he's an er physician,
uh,
vast that,
that he's a well respected aerobatic physician.
And he also has a medical degree and he has a clinic,
also an in Mumbai,
India.
And,
uh,
there,
I also was a typed by professionals and I did what they call a punch,
a Karma,
which is a cleanse.
I pretty much didn't eat anything but this real thin type of soup.
It's just like a broth for a week and then had all sorts of treatments.
It's a,
it's a real good cleansing,
uh,
help the body detoxify,
you know,
this,
uh,
this environment that we live in,
especially in the United States.
You know,
we're just beset with all sorts of pollutants,
air,
water,
toxins in the food.
Your body is capable of reading itself of all that stuff once it's not burdened
by digestion.
Huh.
This is inch.
These questions are very strange.
Yeah.
Well,
what's best describes how you act under stress?
Say your emotions are also geared towards an another words.
Your constitutional type will affect your emotional outlook and even your mental
outlook.
Hmm.
So it's,
you know,
body,
mind and spirit.
They're not looking just at physical symptoms like Western medicine.
They're looking at the whole package.
You know,
what makes Steve Maxwell,
Steve Maxwell,
what makes Joe Rogan Joe Rogan.
So it's,
it's looking at the total package,
the way you think,
you know,
your belief systems,
your emotional system,
your,
your fiscal,
uh,
and no one's just one time,
just one constitutional type of course were mixtures of all these things and
sometimes you can have an imbalance and,
and actually manifest,
uh,
different aspects of,
of,
of other constitutional types.
This is fascinating.
It is very fascinating and it is the oldest medical system.
It's been around for a long time.
Yeah.
I'm filling out this form of trying to find out what I am.
I,
I'm just guessing just from looking at you that you're probably a Kafka,
but perhaps not.
Yeah,
I like to be active.
It's hard to sit still.
Boom.
Enjoy activity that has a purpose.
Especially competitive.
Well,
that's true too.
I like leisurely activities.
I like all three of those.
How do you describe that?
I said I'll go with be competitive,
which best describes your walking style.
Got a walking style.
Yeah,
there's a walking style.
What's the choices?
I walk quickly.
I have a determined walk.
I walk slow and steady at a leisurely pace,
but slow and steady,
deliberately pace as washing your gait.
When you're walking out to the car you walk like a very strong confident kind of
guy that that'd be a cough.
Okay.
Which best describes your mood?
My mood changes quickly.
My moods change slowly.
My moods are mostly steady.
Probably steady.
Seems like a pretty steady Eddie.
Yeah,
pretty steady guy.
Which best describes your memory?
I learned quick and forget quickly.
That's me.
I have a good memory but I have a good memory too.
I learned slowly but I have a good long term memory where you have a hell a mind
for facts and figures but only if I care.
I mean that isn't it that way.
It is with everything.
Cause I mean some of the statistics you come up with on the fighters during the
show,
you know their coaches where they trained the records.
Joe,
your memory is like freaking elephant man.
But that's only if I care about something that I don't care about.
Like people always ask.
I mean like when you're,
when you're talking about fights,
like are you basing this off notes?
No,
I'm almost,
almost all of the stuff that I talk about like during the fights is just stuff
that I remember if I remember fights and it's just mind blowing.
But I do have a sheet that's in front of me that gives me like a fighter's
record but it's very rare that I reference it cause almost all of it is shit.
But that's just because I'm a fan of the sport.
What does,
but if you ask me things about,
I dunno,
the Oliver North trial.
Yeah.
Well you know,
I mean you know your,
your mind only has butts so much capacity.
So I mean
organisation.
What best describes your organization style?
I'm good at getting things started but not,
it's getting things done.
I'm very organized and I can focus on a project from start to finish.
I need help getting things started,
but I am good at seeing things through to the finish.
That's,
I'm neither one.
I'm none of those things.
But sometimes you know the hard times you,
you can be all those things in different situations or we'll just go with a,
all right.
Congratulations.
You finished the quiz.
Wait a moment while we get your results.
Okay.
Be Curious.
I mean,
there's so many different tests for this era of anything though.
Fuck Emma.
Come on.
What's with the gum on?
Trying to come up with the answer.
Okay.
This is indicative of Aveda type.
This is indicative of a pita type.
This is indicative of a calf,
a type.
This is indicative of Peta.
Uh,
I got all of them,
man.
I'm,
I'm all of them.
Well,
I think one is part of each one,
but you're going to pretty big dominately one or the other.
Just say though.
But there's much more in depth test.
So this sucks.
It might've been for all of this.
Might've been a bogus test.
Well,
yeah,
it's probably some westernized test,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
some American version of the ancient tests,
obviously it's an English translations are probably a bit funky.
Okay.
I was,
I was actually typed by a professional with the in the profession.
I found it to be quite true for me personally.
That's interesting.
So you went to an actual specialist to do this?
Yeah,
I did.
And when you find out your body type or you find out there's the dietary regimen
that goes along with this and there's even an exercise that's better,
more beneficial world that's beneficial for different types.
And as the idea of balancing yourself.
Yeah,
you want to keep as balanced as possible and you have to be very careful with
imbalances what manifest all sorts of illnesses,
diseases and so forth.
So food choices and exercise choices.
For example,
I mentioned spice for me is just a terrible cause I don't need to produce any
more heat in my,
in my body.
Excess heat would cause my joints to do dra eight and caused osteoarthritis and
all sorts of stuff.
Why that really?
And that can be caused by spicy food.
By excess heat in the system.
That's correct.
But I didn't know that spicy food actually does generate heat.
I creates inflammation.
Oh hmm.
But say for certain Dosha types,
like the Vata or the coffee,
it could be quite stimulating.
They need that.
Well what's,
what type would be the type that eats a lot of hot food?
Well,
Vod is for example,
or kind of skinny and they have an asymmetry to their body so that can be really
good for them to help energize them.
Uh,
for a cough they tend to put on weight on one at a body,
fat and weight,
and sometimes the more spicy type foods would be good for helping rev up their
metabolism with the Chili and that type of stuff.
That's been shown to why they even put that in some of the fat loss formulas.
Maybe you guys are used to sell one of those fat loss formulas with your,
now that you don't have any fat burners on your thing.
I don't believe in any of that shit.
I really have a coffee.
Do your best to me.
Coffee.
Yeah,
I mean just the caffeine.
Well,
I just think that that,
that weigh out that everyone's looking for fat burners.
It's this,
this one pill fix thing to a very complex issue.
The,
the,
the excess body fat issues are very complex.
It's very complex.
I mean it's,
you know,
emotional,
very emotional with a lot of people going on.
So much going on.
Yeah.
And the idea that you're going to fix that with a pill with a pill.
But see that's one of the problems I have with a lot of supplements.
You know,
I know you sell supplements,
I'm not,
I,
and there was a point you to speak is there was a time when I,
I had like almost a $300 a month hap.
Seriously.
Couple couple of things that uh,
I've come to the conclusion once I stopped,
I didn't notice the damn bit of difference.
But there is a difference between just trying to go for general health and
trying to maximize your potential was competitive athlete when you're trying to
maximize your competitive potential.
Okay.
Maybe this might give you like a one or 2% edge or something,
or 3% but if you're an elite that's maybe all you need to be a champion or,
or when the worlds or something like that,
that's one extra punch,
land extra take down,
defended.
But for general health,
you know,
I mean,
there's not a,
an animal on God's earth that need supplements.
If you think about it,
nature provided everything that every animal on the planet needs.
You know,
think of like how strong a bull gorilla is or,
or a water buffalo or Elian.
I mean,
everything they need is provided by nature and us as the highest form of animal
on the planet.
I mean,
what makes us think that God didn't provide the stuff are nature didn't provide
for us.
It was that,
it was certain people have to be willing to eat it and they're not.
They want to,
you know,
TV dinners and,
and,
you know,
nuke their food in the microwave and,
and,
and so forth.
And you know,
we
were talking about how,
you know,
the damaging sugar is last time and how delicious it is.
And you know,
and,
and these,
these,
uh,
fast food manufacturers,
they're pretty insidious.
I mean,
they know how to drop a taste that is almost literally irresistible.
Some people even say addictive.
Well,
it's certainly addictive.
There's sugars in,
in certain foods and certain fast foods that sugar has been shown to be one of
the most addictive food.
Oh my God,
yes,
like free,
credible,
predictive.
But the problem is when people are taking a lot of supplements,
somehow they have a tendency to think that it's okay to eat that stuff.
And there's a lot say,
but if they feel somehow they're getting it in their pills and their approach to
covering their bases and the powders and all that,
and there's a lot less
desire to go out and eat a proper,
you know,
they don't have the incentive to go out and eat a really good diet.
I mean,
I,
I do online personal training and diet fat loss programs.
I'm shocked when I see the food logs of some of the guys to send it in.
I mean there's no raw fruits or raw vegetables on their menus.
It's like,
wow,
how,
how could you not at least have some,
you know,
and it's all,
cooked,
prepared foods,
canned bottled stuff in plastic wrappers.
It's like wow,
but you know,
that's what's happened to us in modern society.
So yes,
probably there's no real harm and taking some supplements for regular people,
well there's certain things
mentally you're just not going to get the right amount.
With foods like fish oil,
like omega three fatty acids and things along those lines,
like you would have to eat a shit load of fish every day to get the proper
amount to reduce inflammation,
to increased cognitive abilities to help muscle growth.
There's a lot of benefits official that's been shown and it's incredibly
difficult to get that amount of fish oil just from eating fish unless written
salmon,
fatty salmon all day
or,
or getting fish that isn't polluted with mercury and all that crap.
I had a problem once I went to a doctor,
I get blood work done just to see where I'm at and check to see if I'm healthy.
You'll look at,
make sure there's no issues in advance.
And a doctor told me that I had arsenic in my,
in my body,
and I was like,
what?
Like,
like on being poisoned.
Like were you talking about,
he's like,
it's a very low level.
Um,
do you,
do you eat a lot of fish?
And I said,
I eat sardines.
You always eaten like a can of sardines a day,
sometimes two cans a day.
I love sardines.
And he was like,
well,
stop doing that because the sardines live at the bottom of the ocean and they
collect a lot of heavy metals and a lot of pollution.
And uh,
I stopped and it was gone,
but I was getting arsenic poisoning from sardines.
Well,
which is called the Shaker.
Sardines are delicious.
They're a great source of sulfur amino acids,
which you know,
has been tied into,
uh,
anti aging.
So it's a shame.
But yeah,
our food sources are being ruined on the,
on the planet.
Slowly but surely,
slowly but surely.
So as there's no escape from it.
But that's one reason why I like to do the fasting.
Remember I mentioned the Paunch Karma,
this detox name,
your body is able to throw a lot of these toxins off under the right conditions.
How much water are you drinking a day?
You know,
I don't even measure his drink when Thursday.
Pretty much.
You know,
so you don't like have like a big jug that you can put na.
I think a lot of that was overplayed cause yeah,
I just don't think is all that necessary to drink all that much.
Yeah.
When,
when people say it's a weird thing,
like they say you should have x amount of glasses of water a day or a gallon of
water a day.
Like what?
What is,
what does that based on?
I have no idea.
But I do know that one of your best sources for hydration is with raw fruits and
raw vegetables.
And when you're getting a lot of this type of plant stuff,
you're getting plenty of hydration right?
From fruits and vegetables of people that don't have any of that stuff.
Yeah,
they probably do need to drink a little bit more,
but yeah,
I mean for the most part there's a lot of misses or perpetrated out there for no
rhyme or reason,
you know?
And you just wonder where does all this stuff come from?
Yeah,
the water one was a big one.
Like guys would walk around with these giant jugs of water and they would say
that the average person walks around dehydrated all the time,
but I would watch them and they'd be peeing every 20 minutes.
And I was like,
well,
you know,
while you're flushing your body out of toxin,
it's like,
are you sure?
Are you sure?
It sounds to me like you're just overloading your kidneys with a lot of water
for no good reason,
but that
thing,
you know,
everybody's always worried about the toxins of flushing toxins out.
I'm going to go to the sauna,
it's going to flush out the toxins and I'm gonna drink water.
It's going to flush out the toxins.
I'm doing a cleanse.
It's going to take care of my toxins.
Like
there's all these,
it's worried about it for sure.
Cause you know,
the worry,
we won't change it at the end bit.
I ended in favor of overheating bads.
I think it can be a really good thing for longevity.
I mean it's been since the time of American Indians had their sweat lodge,
the Russians and the fins had their,
their,
their saunas.
The Romans were very big on,
on,
uh,
steam,
the Turks and so forth.
The Japanese,
you know,
everyone's used heating therapies for producing a good sweat.
And if you think about it,
the skin's the largest organ in the body and you can eliminate a lot of waste
out through the skin,
through press perforation.
And when you,
uh,
get,
stimulate the skin two to sweat,
you can sweat out a lot of stuff.
Uh,
have you ever heard of infrared sauna?
Yes.
Well,
you know,
infrared Saunas so good at helping the body detoxify that a drug and alcohol
clinics actually install infrared Saunas to help people kick drugs and alcohol
and cigarettes and so forth.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's tried and true.
I mean,
it does work.
And a infrared sauna is way different than the old sod as we used to sit in as
wrestlers,
you know,
trying to just the hotbox,
these infrared Saunas,
the temperatures that doesn't have to be nearly as,
Hi Matt.
My God,
they feel so good.
The very penetrating
and uh,
it's really good for recovery after hard training and so forth.
You'll have to drive one.
Sometimes.
I might even want to look into,
uh,
putting on like a little mini one in your house or something.
I am actually,
my wife has one that she climbs into like a sleeping bag.
It's in some weird sort of infrared sauna and she heats up.
Oh,
that she loves this thing.
That's cool,
man.
Doctor Rhonda Patrick,
one of the people that,
uh,
I've had on the podcast as a regular,
um,
she's a fascinating and she's got so much knowledge.
Um,
and one of the things that she wrote a paper that was recently published,
it's on the benefits of Sauna and a really incredible on a hyperthermic
conditioning on muscle growth.
And,
uh,
oh,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
And she was saying,
you know,
it's,
I would,
I would really not do it justice.
Like it's something that should be read and gone over cause it's a very deep and
in depth paper that she published.
But it's all about,
uh,
the benefits of a,
of the sauna and the uh,
the effect on hormone production and the,
uh,
the effect of a heat stress on the brain.
Really,
really interesting stuff.
He stress has been shown to increase the expression of brain derived neurotropic
factor.
Well,
more,
more than exercise alone when used in conjunction with exercise.
This is important because this brain derived neurotropic factor increases the
growth of new brain cells as well as the survival of existing neurons and
increase in neurogenesis is thought to be responsible for enhancing learning.
Wow.
Incredible.
So exercise and sauna enhances learning.
Well,
like I said,
the ancients were not stupid people.
You know,
we were so smug with our technology.
We are.
Right.
But you know,
you take the average person and take him 50 miles out in the wilderness and let
him go.
He would probably die of fright.
He wouldn't even be,
you know,
and you take it shout even as little as 200 years ago and they would be
perfectly comfortable living in their environment.
You know,
that's what technology has done for us.
We can't even go from point a to point B with that or iPhone or a gps or,
right.
I wonder what's going on with that.
Um,
you know,
when you look at people that used to live a long time ago and you used to be
able to survive out in the woods and survive without technology and then you
look at,
you ever watch that show naked and afraid?
I have not.
It's a fascinating show cause they take people and they take the clothes off and
then they leave them in the jungle.
Oh I did hear about this.
It's the most fucking ridiculous shall ever.
Well by how the,
how do they show that kind of note again,
TV,
they just blur,
blur,
blur out the breasts and blur out their crotch.
And uh,
you know,
it's a couple,
a man and a woman and um,
I don't,
I don't know if they have any sex.
I would imagine they know each other before the shot.
Nope.
Oh yeah,
they're naked together.
Yeah.
It's a fascinating show.
Well,
fascinating.
Depending upon who the contestants are,
you know,
they have a,
I believe it's one days,
which is the most amount of time you can go without any food.
So I think they put them in a place that has an abundant amount of water so they
could find water.
They don't put them in the desert for 21 days.
It'd be fucking dead.
And to,
you know,
they're probably dead.
And one,
you know,
you put someone in death valley with no clothes for a day,
no water,
no clothes.
You got 24 hours.
If you're lucky,
you might not even make it 24 hours.
Right.
And we get to 128 degrees out there and you could just a heat stroke even with
water.
So yeah.
So these people are out there and you know they have to build shelter because
there in the rain forest so there's only as fucking bugs and you know,
they see bullet ants,
bullet ants are the,
oh,
some of the most painful stings known demand.
They say it's like getting your hand slammed in a car door for 24 hours.
That's what it feels like.
If one bites you.
Well I would definitely be naked and afraid of us around fricking bullet.
And as well they have these rites of passages they do with certain indigenous
tribes in the Amazon where they take what looks like oven Mitts and they embed
bullet ants in these oven mitts all throughout that.
Like they,
they like stick their stingers through so they're trapped and so they just keep
stinging and then they make these guys wear these gloves and get the shit stung
out of them by these bullet ants.
And,
uh,
there was one show,
I forgot what the show was,
but the host actually took part in the ritual himself and put these gloves on
his hands.
He got his hands all strong and it sounds crazy and you just watch and just
dropped to his knees.
And just the most intense agony,
unimaginable agony.
And it just lasts forever.
Lasts like hours and hours and hours of intense,
intense agony.
But in getting through it,
it,
um,
not only is it,
like a rite of passage,
but it also is what they call it,
certain tribal
tribal cultures where they do not have access to psychedelics.
So this is like a psychedelic,
the neurotoxins and the venom.
Yeah,
kind of puts you on some kind of altered state.
There's a little bit of that.
And there's also the,
your body develops so much resistance to all the venom that there's probably
some sort of a,
a serotonin boost.
And there's also,
there's things called,
um,
they're,
they're called the,
there's certain certain rituals where it's not a,
it's not called a psychedelic,
it's called a like an ordeal.
Poison and ordeal.
Poison is like what tribes where they don't have access to psychedelics.
Oftentimes they come up with these rituals based on poisoning.
So they'll give someone a poison that gets you to the brink of death,
like gets you like to you,
you're sweating,
you're dying,
and then it releases you when your body processes it.
Like the IOWASCA almost,
but not because I was,
is not poisoned.
I ask it doesn't harm you and in fact I just couldn't use that vomiting,
that severe vomiting.
Yeah,
but that's just because it's disgusting.
It's to gross.
It's and you're taking all this plant matter and it's just horrible.
Foul taste and purging.
Anything that might be in your stomach,
but the active ingredients in,
um,
in Iowasca,
not only is it not toxic,
but it's also one of the most transient drugs ever exhibited a or ever observed
in the body because of the fact that it's a normal norm,
new human neuro transmitter.
Your body knows how to process it so your body just can bring you back to
baseline very quickly.
You know,
I bought some of that stuff one time.
I was it.
Yeah,
I was going to do,
I said I got scared.
Well I read where you really should have a shaman that really knows his stuff.
And I thought,
you know what if I had a bad trip and this stuff man,
where were ya?
But I was living in my camper van at the time out in Arizona in the middle of
the desert.
How long ago was it?
Like what about three and a half,
four years ago.
And I had read about it,
Wasco from Stuart Wilde who said that this is where the spiritual teachers got
to go at some point,
you know,
once you've reached a certain level and he was talking about it.
I was good and I thought that sounds really fascinating.
And it was ridiculously easy to buy over the Internet and have mail ordered
right to my po box.
So was it a fully brood males?
It was just the plant matter,
like the dried herbal stuff,
sealed plastic bag.
And then I looked at it and then I read about the processing and I thought,
you know what?
I probably should just wait on this and do it in Wa wa wait till someone that
really knows what he's doing.
But they,
they had those Iowasca trips that you could take down in Brazil and even in
Mexico,
we're thinking about starting a treatment center in,
in Peru because uh,
yeah,
my partner from Onnit,
Aubrey's been down there so many times his work with these guys.
So many times we're thinking about setting up a program because it's legal
there.
Yeah,
for sure.
Setting up a program through on it where people can travel down there and they
know that they'll have good combinations,
a legit Sharman safe environment.
And you know,
we've had so many requests from so many people that we would love to send you
down there.
I might have to take you up on that job.
Give me a full report and I would love to go with you.
I spend time,
I'm down,
I'm down with it totally fast.
I've been thinking about this for years,
you know?
Yeah.
It's just really something that just sounds fascinating to me because apparently
people have some really amazing psychedelic experiments and just kind of expands
the consciousness and,
and,
and uh,
they have some pretty,
uh,
pretty intense experiences.
But you would definitely want it to be with someone that,
that has taken people through it before.
Definitely not something to mess around with on your own man.
Well,
it's also,
uh,
the environment that you do it in is really important too.
You don't want to be in an unsafe environment.
You don't want to be tripping.
You Paul's off and then something goes wrong.
There's no one there that can handle everything.
Like you don't want to be like caught in a forest fire but flight a tripping on
DMT.
Um,
I've only had the,
um,
the synthesized of it.
The,
the,
the hard version of DMT.
I haven't had the orally active version of it,
which is what Iowasca is.
And again,
you're talking about the ancients,
no one,
their shit,
the,
they weren't full.
They figured out how to combine two different plants to create this,
this mixture.
See DMTs not orally active.
If you took DMT in an oral form model,
Amy knocks days,
which is produced in your gut would,
would kill the DMT.
Um,
so they figured out how to take the leaves of certain plants which have DMT and
or the vines of certain plants which have DMT.
And then the leaves are other plants which have harming,
which is a natural Mao inhibitor.
And then they brew it together and this really sort of complicated process and
develop this Iowasca,
which is essentially it becomes an orally active version of the drug that I
took.
I just smoked it.
You smoke it,
it's intense.
It's very fast.
It hits you within 15,
20 seconds and it only lasts about 15 minutes.
It's sort of,
it's like a,
just a quick shot to the center of the universe.
The most amazing,
unbelievable psychedelic experience you could ever imagine.
I describe it as mushrooms times a million plus aliens.
Unbelievably intense.
I a WASC,
uh,
usually it's a little less intense,
but it's okay.
Prolonged experience.
Many hours.
Several hours.
Yeah.
I read a,
an outside magazine actually about a,
an eye Wasco trip that was organized.
There's a lot of 10 people,
two people didn't get anything.
They just got sick and that was it.
And then eight of the ten one had a bad trip,
like freaked.
And then the other seven had fantastic consciousness raising experience.
I wonder what
makes people trip,
because there's the showman say that the people that have these bad trips of
what's going on is that the trying to fight it,
they're trying to control the situation and your ego doesn't want to let go and
you try to resist and then it just sorta chips away at your inner soul and finds
out,
you know what's causing this resistance and then penetrates it and freaks you
the fuck out.
And you can't,
you can't wrestle with God.
And that's essentially what you're doing when you're having these psychedelic
experiences.
You're trying to wrestle with the creative force of the very universe itself and
this ego thing that people have.
Oh,
don't worry,
I can handle it.
There's so many people that have that I can handle it thing,
you know,
ridiculous.
Overqualified confidence for no fucking reason,
for no reason,
no reason why you think you should be able to handle it,
but you're running big going in.
They're a little afraid.
You probably have great experience and humble and hump raid.
Humble and a frame.
Please
be nice to me.
I give up,
you know,
I'll,
I submit myself to you and then you're going to get through it.
It's not a toxic thing.
It's not a poisonous thing.
The people,
you know,
Terence Mckenna had a line.
The only fears that you may die from astonishment because it's so fucking crazy.
We're all going to die.
Not a bad way to go there.
Yeah.
Well that,
that's what's really crazy is that they believe that the experience that you
have while you're taking DMT is the exact experience
that people have when they're dying.
Because when you're dying,
your brain produces dimethyltryptamine.
It's produced during rem sleep.
Well,
it's in so many different plants.
The reason why your gut produces this model,
Amy and oxidase or uh,
one of the,
one of the reasons probably serves many purposes,
but is that dimethyltryptamine is in a lot of different plants.
So these plants that we eat would give us DMT.
Like you would get high off of certain plants,
like it's in thousands of different plants.
It's a law that you could extract it from just regular grass,
like full arris grass has DMT in it.
Like a lot of it.
And that's why certain sheep will eat grasses that have DMT in it and they die
like immediately.
Like you'll find them like in the field,
they'll the run across a patch of grass that has DMT and their bank legs up,
little little feet twitch.
And so like what might be toxic to a sheep,
not so much to a yacht at all.
Not at all saying,
yeah,
DMT is not toxic at all to humans,
but to,
to sheet.
But just wow,
that's pretty fascinating.
Kills Him.
Don't be a sheep,
but you know,
going back to,
excuse me.
Well we had mentioned earlier about the ancients not being stupid.
You know,
that's basically what aerobatic medicine was based on.
[inaudible] in India.
I mean,
these people had amazing powers of observation and this is,
you know,
pre science.
We put so much faith in science,
but you know,
sometimes you have to think about these,
these so called studies,
you know,
with,
with the agendas and so forth.
And it was definitely a lot of that.
Right.
You know,
of course,
you know,
some monetary incentive.
How many times have we seen drugs being Charlie promoted only to find out later
when they're recalled,
like all these whores,
you know,
like thalidomide in babies back in the 70s or whatever.
But that happens a lot,
man.
Yeah,
less so now than it used to,
but now than it used to it.
But it's still happens.
Well,
there's more transparency now than ever before,
so it makes it much more difficult.
But do you remember a Guy Metzger UFC?
Sure,
sure.
You know,
he got a stroke from Vioxx.
Whoa.
Yeah,
Vioxx.
He's a,
he was having a arthritis issues with knees,
you know,
years of martial arts training.
A lot of guys have problems with her knees.
They're very common.
Chris Weidman recently had both his knee scoped and before that he had gone
through Regena keen on his knees to,
but he said arthritis in his knees.
So bad Weidman can't even pull his heel up to his butt,
you know,
and he's a UFC middleweight champion and his knees are so stiff from all the
years of wrestling and all the years of what were talking about before plowing
through injury,
which is something new,
injury that wrestlers are so accustomed to doing.
No one's in my opinion,
no one's tougher mentally then.
Then amateur wrestlers.
I think the,
the ability to become a successful amateur wrestler,
there's no hidden secrets.
There's the,
the,
the techniques have existed from literally the beginning of human time.
People have learned how to wrestle.
I mean obviously they refined those techniques,
they passed him down,
but
there's no secrets.
It's hard work,
force,
determination,
focus.
That's all it is.
And so who,
who works harder,
who can endure more,
who can punish their body more,
who can show up and put in that extra hour of training every day that the other
guy can't do that?
Guy's probably going to wind up winning.
And so these wrestlers have this ability to plow through injuries
through injury and lot man.
I mean they hurt themselves though.
Yeah,
well it's very,
very hard in the body.
I think of the guys that I wrestled with back in the 60s and the 70s so a lot of
these guys are just,
their bodies are a mess.
You know,
I went to a reunion not too long ago of my old college guys and it was pitiful
off what's happening.
I mean some of these guys just set studs and wow.
They just,
just the hoarseness of the regimen,
you know,
they just kind of let themselves go.
They,
they didn't want to be bothered with that stuff anymore.
Well even guys that you know are still studs but this,
their bodies are slowly giving out that things are breaking off.
Things that hips the back Mark Coleman just got a hip replacement,
you know,
more Dan Gable,
their greatest wrestler ever.
You know,
he went through the Munich Olympics unscored on because it's,
I imagine Olympic level tournament and the Russians had swore they're going to
find a guy to beat him.
They guy went through the tournament without being scored on unbelievable forms.
An animal who our guy double hip replacement as saw knees as well.
I think it's Niesr it needs to get his knees replaced as well.
So I mean,
but you know,
sometimes you think like,
was it worth it?
I,
I think when he asks a lot of these guys,
you don't have the glory that they have,
they might say,
yeah,
it was worth it because the long life of never having done anything,
I mean that,
that's not worth,
that's not a life worth living either,
in my opinion.
Yeah,
it's a tough call because we're all good
die.
And eventually all of our bodies will give out.
And that's one of the things that I wanted to talk to you about because you,
uh,
early on in one of your early DVDs,
one of the first ones that I got,
which boy,
I dunno when,
when did you put out your first DVD?
My God,
I don't even know.
It's been a long time.
At least 15 years ago.
I got one of the earliest ones.
So you're probably,
you were probably about my age actually.
You're probably about 46,
somewhere around that.
Yeah.
And you were talking about the,
um,
the aging process of fighting off the aging process and uh,
exercising to fight off that aging process and being conscious about doing that.
And that's something that I think very few people do.
They just work out to be in shape.
They work out the same shape.
But you were one of the first guys that ever saw that was talking about it
pretty actively on a DVD and teaching people strategies and techniques to fight
off the aging process,
not just through exercise,
through manipulating your hormones through certain types of exercise in joint.
So I'm
about is so important because all the dead lifts and Kettlebell snatches and
swings and the water and not going to save,
save you as you begin to get older,
you got to keep that mobility workup.
A lot of people don't understand what you mean by mobility.
They get very confused with the flexibility they are,
they are related,
but as basically being average to move through full range and,
and keeping complete joint function.
And there's specific exercises that a person can do to,
to enable them to do this.
And it feels damn good actually.
And I've studied the Russian systems,
you know,
there's like a Slavic health system and Russian system.
They,
uh,
really developed the mobility to very,
very,
very high level.
And I was lucky enough to learn this stuff.
And then of course I added a lot of the stuff I learned from Yoga and so forth
in there.
And uh,
I came up with this system for myself.
Then I teach to people in my seminars and so forth.
And um,
it's really kept me going.
I mean I could ended up like all my comrades,
you know,
the guys that wrestled with back in the sixties and seventies and of course I
been doing,
she sits there now for almost 23 years and competed pretty high level in the,
in the age group divisions and that takes its toll.
But thank God for the mobility.
It kept me fairly,
uh,
I mean I can't say I got through it completely unscathed,
but it definitely kept my joints in tech and I'm able to move pretty damn good.
And when I look at people in my family tree,
you know,
my,
my relatives,
my grandparents and so forth,
I mean they were moving bad.
I mean,
just really bad.
And uh,
I,
I vowed that that wasn't going to be me.
So with this system that I use,
if this mobility it,
it keeps me pretty spry.
Now what do you,
how often do you do it?
Like every single day.
Every single day.
So give me a,
like a schedule,
like how do you,
what do you do?
How do you start out your day with it?
Like,
well,
generally speaking,
I'll get up.
I have a whole era vedic therapy that I go through,
you know,
get up.
Yeah,
I'll scrape my tongue with a tongue scraper.
This is,
uh,
there's a lot of stuff from the night sleeping all night.
You know,
you build up,
uh,
substances on the tongue.
You'll be shocked at what you see.
It comes off the tongue when you wake up in the morning,
you know,
obviously toothbrushing head massage and then I had massage,
head massage.
Do you do it yourself?
Yes.
I also have like a special little scraper thing,
you know,
like little fingers that you really massage the head.
Then I use a Neti pot and Eti it's an aerobatic technique where you rinse your
sinuses so he can breathe through the nose really,
really well.
And nasal breathing is really important.
Uh,
then I do a dry brush massage.
it's a,
it's basically a German Swedish Russian thing where you just every inch of the
skin you brushed with a natural bristle brush because your skin's the biggest
working in the body.
So you really want to keep it.
And this dry brush massage really is quite excellent for the skin,
stimulates the skin to,
you know,
to new renewed growth.
It gets rid of dead skin cells.
It keeps it really nice and you're your complexion.
Good.
And I'll scrape,
you know,
I'll,
I'll brush the body and then I,
I take a cold water therapy,
very big into cold water.
I used to do dancing with the ice cold water in a bucket,
but since I travel,
I pretty much have to use the shower.
She'd just take a cold shower.
Oh.
Sometimes they'll do alternating hot and cold shower La.
It's not too bad.
You know,
Allie,
you know the waters,
it doesn't get too cold.
But sometimes like a,
as a in Portland,
Oregon,
and before that,
Toronto,
the waters,
the frosting and then there's a,
there's a whole towel treatment that I learned also in a towel treatment.
Yeah.
There's a way that you can briskly use a uh,
course towel rather than having these soft towels.
You make him sort of like,
they're almost sandpaper.
And I learned it from this Russian guy,
this old Russian sauna and master who show me how to do this.
Very vigorous Tao rubdown.
Of course,
all of the old timers knew about this stuff.
You know,
a lot of the,
uh,
you know,
mighty men of old,
George's hacking,
Schmidt,
the Russian lion and,
and you know,
uh,
air where and,
and painful a roller.
A lot of these old health pioneers,
uh,
brag,
McFadden,
Harvey Kellogg,
all these turn of the century guys.
the guy from Kellogg's.
Yeah.
Do you know how crazy that guy,
he's pretty crazy.
Well,
we were talking about him on the podcast yesterday.
That guy,
he used to take,
uh,
he created Kellogg's and created the bland cornflakes.
Yes.
To keep people from masturbating.
He bragged about never having sex with his wife.
[inaudible] they were together for 40 years,
but he would have a daily enema by his handsome male assistant.
Oh,
give them a daily Anima.
Well,
hey,
it's pretty crazy.
Oh yeah.
He was about as crazy as you can.
Well they they go and use this towel,
really overly concerned about bowel function.
Some of these guys and sex and sex is all that weird Victoria and stuff going on
there.
The township we had been and then I'll do the five rights of Tibetan Yoga.
That's how much time does all this tank.
About 30 minutes for the whole thing.
Just scraping the tongue and cold shower,
the whole deal.
There's the five rights can be done very quickly.
And what is the five rights?
Uh,
it's a spinning a,
there's like a leg race type thing,
a thing where you lean back a table maker and uh,
uh,
as an exercise called the pump,
like uptown dogs,
it hits every part of the body.
It stimulates the hormonal system.
Uh,
the,
the practitioner who's claimed it realigns the shockers where they call it the
vortex people can,
if they want to Google it,
they can download a free pdf.
It's a book called the eye of the revelation and they can read all about it.
It was written by a British army major that happened to be stationed in the
northern territories of India and DePaul.
And he observed these,
these monks,
these Tibetan monks and how spry and how young they were and how even these guys
in their late eighties were able to bound up and down the side of the Himalayan
mountains somewhat effortlessly.
And he noticed it took great note of their exercise system,
which was basically these five exercises every morning along with the,
uh,
are you familiar with the prostration exercise where you,
you,
you sort of like lay down in your stomach and prostate yourself to a prostrate
yourself,
a prostate,
frustrate yourself to a Buddha as a,
as a sign of devotion.
It's pretty,
pretty tough little exercise.
So what do you do?
You,
you lie on your stomach and you lift your legs up.
It's like doing an ab wheel and it's,
it's pretty tough man.
And uh,
you know,
like one of the things that differentiates old from young is your ability to get
up and down off the four.
You know,
think about it.
Like my mom for example,
I,
I've visited and she's not listening to podcasts,
but I mean poor soul,
you know,
she's like almost 80 but she was bent over with their back to the side front.
I don't think she should get up and down off the four.
I don't believe she could.
I think it'd be really hard.
I don't think my dad could either.
You know?
And he actually ran and lifted weights most of his life,
but he didn't pay any attention to mobility or flexibility training and he's
still alive and,
yeah.
Yeah.
Do you talk to him about,
I mean,
there's gotta be weird when you've got a son that's this health and fitness
expert and you don't pay attention to it at all.
Yeah.
It's just the way parents are sometimes.
I mean they just don't want to listen to their kids,
but,
but I mean that's what it's in my genetic code.
That's what it's in my genetic trick.
So getting up and down off the four is really,
really important.
And a lot of people can't do it.
When I used to run my gym,
matricide is that personal training studio in there.
Besides my Jujitsu school,
I would have people come to me that were only in their forties.
That had a hell of a time getting up and down off the forum.
So bill don't,
well,
I mean we're,
we're grapplers you and I,
I mean,
we're used to it.
So most of the people we know,
no problem.
It shocking Joe when you see what's going on out there.
I may just utterly shocking every time I'd come from a uh,
uh,
you know,
from being overseas and I come back to the states,
I'm just blown away with the obesity and,
and just the poor general health and just how bad people do you think that's
just the peripheralization of sugar in the Diet?
Corn,
Corn Syrup?
I mean,
all those things,
you know,
just the whole,
just the whole set and dairy lifestyle sending,
you know,
majority of people spend most of the time sitting down,
they think of it this way.
Imagine you work out an hour a day,
which is a lot.
Most people do not work out an hour a day.
I think it's estimated that maybe 14% of the population actually works out at
all and there's claiming mowing the lawn and walking the dog is exercise.
Right?
So really serious.
Hardcore exercises are few and far between.
It seems like millions of people are doing it to you and I because they're the
people we hang out with.
Right.
But most,
you know,
most of those other people are not doing it.
So let's say you do work out an hour a day,
but then you're sitting most of the day,
right?
It's the new smoking sitting.
So you're going,
you're sitting in the car to go to war.
He's sitting at the breakfast table.
Then you send the car to go to work or the train or the bus.
You sit at the desk all day.
Then you go to lunch,
you sit some more,
go back to the office,
sit some more,
sit in the car going home.
Then you sit down and Facebook or you,
you know,
you answer your emails,
whatever.
Then you sit down,
watch some television,
then you're lying in bed.
Once your body going to adapt to 23 hours a pretty much sitting on your ass or
sleeping in bed or moving for sure you're going to adapt to that setting despite
the fact that you're working out.
If not enough people aren't moving enough and any movement patterns that you
don't use on a regular basis,
you quickly lose.
And a lot of people,
they just never,
you know,
they use exercise machines and so forth.
Well even if they use barbells or whatever cat,
you know,
they're not getting up and down off the form unless they're doing the turkeys
get up or something.
That's one reason why I think it's such a fantastic exercise.
And by the way,
well unlike Turkish getups as well,
for Jujitsu,
I think it's one of the best exercises.
What's his best all around core strength and for that every important ability to
manipulate a body that's on top of you.
You know,
if you can,
you know,
you can get a kettle bell and you can press that thing and then you could stand,
stand up.
I'll holding that kettle bell that that's,
uh,
that goes a long way to be able to get up from the bottom when someone's on top
of you.
But even just for the general population,
I mean just the ability to get up and down off the floor,
all of those movement patterns that you need to sit up in the elbow on the hand,
you know,
and it's kind of like standing up in base,
Eh,
you know,
like in,
in Jujitsu and then transferring the weight and I mean all those things are
appropriate receptive movements and so forth.
And I think it's really one to,
as things you can do,
but just getting up and down even with your body weight using like this.
Um,
prostration exercise is fantastic.
It's really good stuff.
What do you think about,
um,
if you ever seen Steve Cotter has this exercise that I got from him?
Were you?
Um,
you take two kettle bells.
You lie on your back,
like a,
like you're doing a sit up,
you press them and then you sit up with the kettle bells.
You sit up with them pressed and you do a sit up essentially,
and then you drop back down and then you do it all with your arms fully
extended.
You know,
it's I think calls it a power sit up or something like that.
That's a hell of a hell yes.
Yeah.
Some people call him brushing and set ups and it just crush it.
Right,
right.
Especially with kettle bells.
Right.
Especially with cannabis.
But yeah,
I mean it's a hell of a movement.
I mean for sure.
Nothing wrong with that.
Then as well I like,
I mean obviously you wouldn't take a deep condition businessman and start out
with a movement like that.
That's a good term,
deconditioned businessman.
I have a friend who's a great guy,
but I went to hug him the other day
and you know,
I hugged him,
I put my hand on his back and I was like,
I was thinking of,
I didn't say anything,
but I was thinking to myself like,
how does it even support your spine?
And if there's nothing on your back,
like you grab a grappler or you go hug them and you feel their back,
you feel muscles,
you feel like you can feel the lats and they're back.
Just spinning muscles sticking out there.
And it was just this gooey like thing like go man,
keeps his spine just barely hanging on.
And is it any wonder that people were in pain or that,
you know,
these pharmaceutical companies are just pumping out painkillers,
right?
Overlap.
Yeah.
Unfortunately,
you know,
it's just masking the symptoms so people don't have an incentive then to get in
there and do something about it.
They just covered up with the,
you know,
but the painkillers,
I've been,
um,
pretty shocked at how much I'm decompression or relieves a lot of,
uh,
a lot of pain in the back and about,
how much,
uh,
I take one of these harnesses and I attached to the top of a door and a strap my
neck in it.
And,
uh,
like after I trained especially I like to do that and I just,
it sort of just like pulls on your head and you could pull the string tick,
tick,
tick and it pulls you up and then it puts even more tension.
I like to give it like a lot of weight.
I like to put a lot of weight on it and when it's done it's like Ah,
I feel there's like Russia blood through my neck and it's amazing how good it
feels like as long as you make sure that sucker is tied down good to the the
door.
Cause one time it wasn't and it bounced off and clock me on the fucking head.
And I had a cut on my head for like a couple of weeks.
It was right when I was doing my Scifi thing too.
So I was doing all these uh,
pressed junk or to the big fucking scar on my head.
But um,
when it's,
when it's done correctly,
it's,
it's locked into place.
It's a real good feeling like to stretch.
I used
inversion boots,
I loved the inversion boots and there was a time when I actually injured myself.
I was actually trying to do the AB wheel,
like Jackie Chan's down from the feet and that was pretty good at it.
But I just,
what's tracking chance?
Oh,
there was a movie one time with Jackie Chan using an abdominal whale and he
looks like an inchworm.
He's just going like boop,
boop,
boop.
It was just amazing.
And I had developed the ability to go from the toes completely out and come
back.
But I went to deep and fatigue and a kink,
kinked my back and get myself a horrible case of Sciatica.
I actually rotated vertebrae,
subluxation rotation.
And uh,
what spawned your thesis?
I went to my Ra for is the first time I ever heard the word surgery coming out
of her mouth because she was pretty anti surgery and she said,
I don't know Steve,
you really did it to yourself.
This title,
I don't whether I can help you.
And in the meantime I had this burning sensation down my leg into my knee and my
big toe just wouldn't stop burning with this chronic aching,
burning sensation that was just agonizing.
And what is that?
Is that nerves?
Yeah,
the nerve is pinched off.
So over time I went,
I went to a acupuncture guy to relieve some of the pain.
It had instant relief,
but then it would come back and over time she kept working this vertebrae back
into place with their fingers.
And after about eight weeks,
boom,
it went away.
Like nothing ever happened.
It just disappeared.
But after that I was using that.
Um,
I was also sitting on this chair called a back chair.
It may be,
could bring it up,
but it holds you around the ribs,
like a clamp and you're sitting on a sling and then you release the sling and
your back goes into traction and you're being held up underneath your armpits.
So relieving man.
So you're being held under your armpits,
but like a big clamp,
it kind of clamps onto you.
And so it's sort of like your body's just kind of hang in there and traction and
decompressing like a dip almost kind of like it.
Yep.
Except ears.
No stress in your upper body.
You're just sitting like I am in this chair right now and this back chair was
fantastic.
So between acupuncture,
the back chair and the Rolfing,
she got me out of trouble.
And needless to say,
I wasn't too keen about the APP we owe anymore.
Not at least from the feet.
I was a lot more conservative.
Hanging leg raises.
It's the same damn move.
And except you're in suspension and your bag is in traction.
Much safer exercise.
Right.
So what do you were talking about the kind that you put your feet in the wheel.
I was holding on like one of those little cheapy like $10.
Think what he's doing right here.
Exactly.
Now what I was actually doing it just like that,
but I just went too deep into fatigue and kicked my lower back.
And so you were just too tired.
I was too tired.
I've lost my form a little bit.
I was going too hard.
That is the main issue that we talked about before.
The last time you hear about crossfit,
I finally brought myself to watch the video of that guy getting paralyzed.
Oh my God.
And horrible.
You know what's really telling about that video is not just we're talking about
is there was a crossfit competition and there was a guy who was a crossfit
instructor that was doing a clean,
was it a clean press?
What was it?
Was it,
what was the exercise?
I don't know.
Anyway,
he had the bar over his head lost control of it and it fell on the back of his
neck.
Yeah,
no,
I hadn't actually seen it.
Was it a thruster or,
I'm not.
I don't remember what it was,
but my point is he was in competition with another guy who his body failed on
him right before this guy,
like the guy next to him in the middle of it.
His legs just gave out and he dropped the bar and so he drops his bar and it
hits him on the neck.
So it's like one guy drops his bar and then the next guy drops his by right next
to him.
It's just the next guy was a catastrophic injury.
Catastrophic.
Both guys were so fatigued,
they shouldn't have been doing it in the first place.
They shouldn't have been lifting that way.
No Way,
man.
Not a whole body like that rubber,
you know,
it's like we said last time,
the,
the risk to benefit ratio,
you know,
are the risk worth it.
You've seen the video.
I haven't
actually seen it.
Let's watch it because I,
I,
well why are you bringing that up?
I'm going to take a quick,
okay.
Please do.
Please do it.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Just doing a snatch.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
It's so horrible to see.
And by the way,
I'm not down against exercise,
you know,
in any other,
anybody else's methods.
And I know the people,
some people like crossfit and they get a great deal of,
uh,
of pleasure out of that kind of exercise and pushing themselves and all that
stuff.
And I understand it.
I get it.
Um,
but this is hard to watch,
man.
Watch this guy.
See,
oh Jesus.
Well this is,
this is,
um,
this is the guy that got injured.
The guy to the right of him,
the right on the right of the screen.
He,
uh,
he heard himself right before this.
See,
he's got this and then it just drops and hits is,
oh,
but his body gave out first and then it hit his back on the way down.
It's so awful,
man.
The guy next to him to his left,
if there's another video where you could see,
um,
a few moments before his body gives out,
the God who has left his body gives out too,
just in a different way.
His legs just keep,
yeah,
that guy there.
See,
he'd already,
his body had already given out and his legs went rubber on them.
Exercise is awesome.
It's really awesome.
It's great.
It's great for your body,
but God damn,
man,
you gotta be real careful when you're throwing real heavyweights over your head
and you're completely,
totally exhausted.
I just,
um,
I just don't think it's the right way to do it.
And listening to Steve Talk about the importance of when you're doing these
Olympic movements like Olympic power lifting movements,
they're supposed to be done like rear very small reps like one and two and three
reps.
These are like explosive exercises.
They're supposed to be done just for just,
just for developing strength.
I don't think you're supposed to do them at high repetition.
I know some people get away with it.
I know some people do it,
but God damn,
it just doesn't seem to be the right way to go.
Take care of your meat wagon.
Ladies and gentlemen.
The problem I have with crossfit,
most of it is the same problem that I have with people who are vegans.
They cannot shut the fuck up about being involved in crossfit.
They would just ear beat you to death about crossfit.
But in all fairness,
with all objective thinking and introspective thought,
uh,
when I first started doing Jujitsu,
I couldn't shut the fuck up about Jujitsu.
So maybe it might just be something that you know when people are excited about
something.
By the way,
Jamie,
you were wrong.
The over under,
you said 35 minutes or an hour and a half.
I'll do that.
I'm feeling great.
This is fine.
You know what's fucking a little bit painful is my shins.
It's weird to have your shins press down.
Um,
maybe a home doing it wrong,
but uh,
my back feels great.
There's definitely feels better than,
uh,
I usually feel when I'm leaning up against the back of the chair.
I'm usually trying to like keep my posture straight,
but I always fail.
But with this thing,
look at me dude.
Fucking locked down.
Sorry.
Complete straight line kid.
That's what you're supposed to be.
Just like that.
And that's how he's supposed to set.
How many people actually have one of these fucking things in their office
though?
No.
The other thing they tell you,
you should stand,
stand at your desk.
That's like you ever go to a concert and you have to fucking stand standing
sucks.
It's not fun to stand standing at your desk like it would be so distracting.
That's the same thing.
Oh,
there's a different one.
It's the opposite.
What is that?
Oh,
it's leaning a kneeling chair review,
Huh?
Yeah.
It's a different kind of where she's sitting on it wrong.
That bitch doesn't know what she's doing.
Maybe she turned it around or something like that.
Although it,
notice her spine is straight though.
Somehow it's not like hump,
I like that they caught focuses or anything.
So I mean it's not as bad as maybe slouching down,
you know?
Right.
So if it,
her chair was flat instead of like leaned forward.
Cause I mean it is possible to like lean in this manner and still keep your
spine straight if you have to.
You've got to talk into the microphone,
otherwise folks aren't gonna hear what the hell yeah.
Lean forward.
Yeah.
Eh,
but the worst thing is to not your back do this and you're right foot forward.
And that's what causes that permanent a hump in the upper back day.
They call it a kyphosis or dowager's hump or whatever.
And uh,
so that leaning forward that she was doing it and that chair probably isn't
nearly as bad as,
oh well I was going on there.
I don't know,
but look at that head.
What does that can't be good.
That's not good.
That's called forward head.
Okay.
So get that.
That's not good.
The way she looked,
kind of like this.
You know,
it's real interesting because,
uh,
I worked with a high powered lawyer one time,
remember,
I don't know whether you remember this,
but a,
remember the south Philly Gang?
Uh,
the Nicky Scarfo a mobster,
I worked out the guy that put him in jail.
Whoa.
Yeah.
He was one of my clients.
My clocks fucking stress.
Uh,
that guy was under stress.
He was working like these ridiculously long hours.
I mean,
like 14,
15 hours.
He barely had time to train.
So we came up with a plan and you know,
we had talked about a stability ball.
So Mike swapped out his desk chair for Stability Ball and we've got them a
pedometer.
So he was trying to average like 10,000 steps a day.
And he was like taking the stairs instead of the elevator or escalator.
Uh,
he would park his car as far away as he could just to force himself to walk
extra paces.
Just to go places.
He would walk during lunch and then eat at his desk.
But he also put it in like one of those standup desk and would pace during phone
calls and or pace back and forth while we sorted and swapping out his papers and
this and that.
Dick doing dictation to a secretary.
He ended up losing like 14 pounds during that time.
And you know,
he had,
he had the extra padding on his body and then would come to me and we would do
two 20 minute workouts a week just to keep his basic strength levels up.
And he was very successful and um,
yeah,
he prosecuted a little Nicky Scarfo put his ass in jail.
I would just think that the stress of putting away murderers,
just the idea that you're the guy who's processing,
especially the mob.
Yeah,
that's a real murderer.
That's a real murder and a murder that's connected to a bunch of other murders
that,
you know,
have a vested interest in keeping him out of jail.
Did he get,
I mean,
he had to be like threatened all the time.
Right.
You know,
it never came up.
I mean he never talked about that aspect of it.
But yeah,
I you would think that there would definitely be like some type of threat there.
Yeah.
I mean if you're the guy that's putting a major mob figure in behind bars,
you would have to be a little,
little leery.
You know what's shocking to me?
Um,
I don't know what if different police departments have different standards that
they have for a physical fitness or for self defense.
But when training,
when a guy would come in and they tell me that he's a police officer and he
literally can't defend himself at all,
it is shocking.
Well,
you know,
so common though
because of the,
this whole equal rights and all this stuff and I'm not against equal rights,
but they really dumb some of the standards down in some of the police forces to
make room for,
for women.
And there was these little tiny women on the Philadelphia police force.
I swear to God,
any 12 or 13 year old kid could just take their gun and beat him up.
I,
it just scared the,
the only thing they could do and his situation where someone would be resist
arrest would be lethal force.
What other avenue where they have,
I mean maybe pepper spray or macers you know,
a taser,
but I mean this is back in the day I,
we did a lot of work with the police and law enforcement with Jujitsu and uh,
I was utterly shocked sometimes when some of these people would come in the uh,
the national park service guards,
the,
you know,
the guys that wear the little mounting hats that are hard and all the national
monuments and so forth.
How those guys were licensed to carry guns sometimes was just mind blowing.
It's like,
wow,
dude,
you were so overweight and so obese and so immobile,
you know,
how are you going to put somebody under arrest when you can just barely even
mobilize yourself?
You know,
it's,
it's shocking what happens sometimes.
And you know,
a lot of the cops that come to my seminars and so forth though are grey.
You know,
most of the guys that go to my seminars are pretty motivated,
right.
To stay in shape,
but you know,
not,
not so with their comrades,
it's,
yeah,
no,
I've met a lot of comps through martial arts,
you know,
and uh,
it's one of the reasons why I have a good opinion of cops is because I know so
many of them that are good people,
great people,
man.
There's a lot of folks out there that,
you know,
really shouldn't be doing that job.
They can't handle that stress.
Or even if they could handle that look,
stress levels vary day to day.
Who knows what's going on in people's personal lives and how that manifests
itself in a job like being a police officer.
But if you're a fat fuck on top of that,
Jesus Christ,
and I mean,
I can't tell you how many times I've seen guys come to the gym and they've never
had any training before and there were already a police officer and you're like,
what did,
what would you do if somebody just tackled you?
Like,
what would you do if you didn't have your hand on your gun at the time?
And even then if a guy smacks it and he goes flying and he's on turn as much
good,
you're a dead man.
Like you don't have any,
I would think that that would be like a writer who doesn't know how to spell or
it doesn't know how to type or doesn't literally doesn't know how to write
English language.
Like to be a police officer and not be physically fit or not have any knowledge
whatsoever of self defense.
It seems insane.
It is insane.
There's a very famous training video that they show the,
I think it was in Texas where there was a pretty big guy,
he's probably about two 50 huge cop,
but obviously very fat and out of shape and these two little guys that tackle
him down and take his gun and shoot him.
It's used as a training video for you know,
new recruits and so forth.
And boy that wouldn't give you the incentive to like at least learn some basic
self defense on top of whatever they show in the police academies and so forth.
You know,
I mean,
it's pretty crazy,
but you know,
those guys,
they do have a hell of a hard job.
But you know,
not,
you don't meet Nice people when you're a cop,
you're meeting the worst elements of society every single day.
People just lying to your face.
No wonder they,
you know,
develop high stress levels,
having people lying to you and then having to determine are they telling the
truth or are they lying?
And you know,
criminals are pretty devious and they're pretty good alliance.
Well,
no,
that even most folks that aren't criminals,
if you get caught doing something that's a crime,
they're going to lie.
And so the cops are just constantly dealing with people at their worst,
at their worst element,
you know?
So,
yeah,
I mean,
that would definitely have an impact on the way you think and your stress
levels.
And of course,
we all know that food is a great bomb.
A,
you know,
[inaudible] it's soothing.
It starts when you're a little kid,
you know,
with your,
your dessert or your little treat or in a rewarding kids with the [inaudible].
I hope you don't don't
do that to your kids.
But anyway,
don't use food as a reward.
No,
but I don't demonize food either.
of course not.
You know,
I don't,
I give my kids healthy food most of the time,
but I also say,
who wants to get ice cream?
Well,
let's do it.
Yeah,
of course.
Nothing wrong with that too.
I mean,
sugar's not good ever.
And I tell them that like,
this is not good for you,
but it tastes delicious.
So we limited.
I try to talk to them like,
I mean I have a six year old and a four year old,
so I tried to talk to them like they're adults and then when they,
what does that mean?
Then I explain it.
You know,
I treat them like they're children,
obviously with a lot of love and affection and a lot of patients,
but I try to talk to in a,
in an advanced way.
I don't treat them like they're dummies.
Like I explained to them,
I said,
you know,
food is exactly what your body is built of your body.
Whatever you take in,
that's all that your body has to build new cells.
That's all it has.
It doesn't have any extra stuff.
It only has what you give in as far as food.
So it's important to give your body vitamins.
It's important to give your body all sorts of things like protein and water.
And then,
but I also say,
but it's important to fuck off every now and then.
I don't say fuck off.
My wife wasn't around.
She gets upset at the bad word.
She doesn't want to learn the bad words early.
But uh,
I see sooner or later for sure.
I have a little mouth party with some sugar every now and then,
you know,
but I don't want it to be a forbidden.
Yeah,
well yeah,
once you forget
bid something,
it,
it makes it even more desirable.
And I had friends that had kids and they did not,
you know,
they weren't allowed to have any kind of treats or any of that kind of stuff.
Guess what they do as soon as it goes to a friend's house,
freak out and then break out of that stuff.
Man,
it's so funny.
I had this one lady that was like this really,
really snippy eater and you know,
everything was fresh and organic and she was so proud of her son and his diet
that she had them on.
Man.
Every time I saw that kid,
he was with a friend,
but they would sneak bags of candy and stuff.
So crazy.
It really true.
How many people do that too?
It's so crazy how many people just,
they do that to their kids and they suppress them.
I have a friend whose kid is overweight and he's always like on her,
like telling her,
don't eat this,
don't eat that.
And he'll do it publicly in front of people and shame the kid and it's a
terrible way to deal it,
to do it.
And then when no one's around,
like she was at a party the other day and I watched her just eating,
eating cupcakes and just looking around and eating like,
like rant.
Just frantically stuffing them in her face.
He's going to create a bulemia or okay.
A real problem or someone that has a serious eating disorder.
So yeah.
Shame,
shame never works,
man.
Yeah.
It's terrible.
It's just a bad thing to do to a kid.
It's just,
you know,
children,
they're developing.
And that's the thing that people don't understand.
Like to,
to raise a kid.
It's,
you can't just go on your instincts.
He can't like say,
Oh,
you need to toughen them up and tell him what to do and know you're going to
develop all sorts of weird,
crazy things in their head.
You're going to develop blocks and they're going to have these mental blocks.
They're going to have to work out in therapy for the rest of their life.
If you fuck with her head too much when they're little.
Well,
I mean,
think about it.
Most of us didn't have that greater role model.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's,
there's no directions that come with raising a kid.
Exactly.
And it makes me wonder why so many people think that they are good,
uh,
or even qualified to be parents.
I mean,
nowadays with the world being the way it is,
I would be really reluctant to want to bring another soul into this world.
And I don't know.
I just don't feel like most people are really that qualified to be be parents.
They should really think about why are they doing this?
It seems like kids are almost an accessory,
you know,
something that you show off or as an accessory or,
or they just bring him in because it's the thing to do or whatever,
you know?
It gives them meaning.
It gives our lives meaning I think for a lot of folks,
they feel like if they don't have children that they're there somehow or another
not contributing.
And I have,
I faced that before I had children.
People would say to me like,
Oh,
you know,
one day you're going to have to grow up and you're going to have to have kids.
Right now you're living like Peter Pan.
Let me tell you something.
You know,
that ain't the way to live.
And,
and they,
they make it like there's some nobility and to having children.
I couldn't disagree with that more.
I think if you want to have a life where you contribute a life where you're a
person who is a,
is a beneficial person to society,
it's a real simple,
have good friends,
do something you love doing,
inspire others,
you know,
be nice to folks.
That's it.
That's all you really have to do.
You don't have to have kids like,
and if you have kids and you fuck up and you have shitty kids,
you've done the opposite.
Now you've created problems.
Like I had a friend who used to always rag on people for a,
you know,
like that hadn't,
hadn't reproduced but he was a degenerate and is one of his kids smoked crack.
The other kid was in jail.
I mean,
and he was like bragging about having kids like you fucking idiot.
You've created disasters when your kids come into the room.
I leave
created more of a problem for sa is this idea that not,
not in his eyes,
but you know it's,
yeah,
it is funny.
There is a pressure on people.
It's too bad.
It's,
it's unnecessary pressure.
You know?
And by the way,
you could always just work out,
you know,
all that.
You could go in and volunteer your time.
A youth center.
Plenty of people.
Kids rather have,
yeah,
exactly.
They don't have good mentors or parents or whatever,
fathers,
kids and so forth.
The thing that really bugs me and you see this and Jujitsu or martial arts a lot
where guys give up their dreams for the kid.
Like the sacrifice,
everything for the kid.
What a horrible role model.
What,
what message is that?
I am this.
I am so important.
I'm the center of the universe and kids grew up with this,
you know,
they talk about lack of self esteem.
I think most modern kids have too much esteem.
They've been,
you know,
they grew up like a little prince or a little princess and it's like man,
the best thing a guy could do is continue to work out.
Keep yourself in great shape.
Take that time for yourself to keep yourself healthy.
Cause I mean what use is a man to his family if he's broken down and sick and he
just works his ass off all the time.
And it doesn't keep himself healthy.
And my God,
go,
go to the Mat and get your time in man.
You know,
to keep yourself mentally healthy and happy.
But I can't tell you how it used to bug me when I had my Jujitsu school.
How many guys,
you know,
they let family,
uh,
just completely undermine everything that you were doing for the health and
their wellbeing and their,
their split.
Every,
their kid becomes like
a project and they put tremendous amount of pressure on their kid because of
that.
You know,
I think it's very important to set an example and one,
one of the best examples that you could have as a parent.
It's just to live a balanced life,
to live a fulfilled life,
enjoy yourself,
enjoy your time.
So the kid has like that in their head.
Like,
Oh,
I,
you know,
I should,
I should I see how my mom lives her life.
I see that she's fulfilled.
I see that she enjoys,
she has hobbies,
she enjoys.
She likes to educate herself.
She likes to read,
she likes to do things.
I like to do things too.
And like,
you get stimulated if you have a mom,
it's a fat fuck that sits around and watching real housewives of Beverly Hills
and eating Cheetos and complaining about people and Talking Shit.
You know,
those kids will develop that sort of a habit.
They'll start talking shit to and they'll start floundering around.
Two children imitate their atmosphere,
you know,
very much so.
And you know,
like the old man has been working all day and he comes home and he's grouchy.
He's tired,
you know?
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden he's dumped on with all the,
all the problems.
Oh yeah.
When my kids were little man,
I would put them in the damn playpen and they could scream their fucking heads
off and I did my training and they were going to learn that,
hey,
for that time,
Hey,
I'm doing my thing.
I was making sure they weren't hurt.
Right.
But it wasn't going to kill him.
You know,
and then I would,
how old were your kids when,
or your kid when you got divorced?
Uh,
let's say the daughter was 12,
going on 13,
and Zach was like,
I guess 14.
That's it.
Just tough on kids.
That's tough on kids.
And especially at that age,
right at the high school age,
close to him.
Well the girl more so than the boy,
that was tough for her as Zach.
He was a little bit more philosophical.
It's a pretty mature kid for his age and he was able to just take it in,
stride it
a bit more.
Yeah.
When kids see parents that are together too,
you know,
they,
they look at these like happy households.
Like,
uh,
some of my daughter's friends,
um,
they're single moms or they're broken up with her husband are going through
divorce and you can see they,
they hate it.
The kids,
the,
you know,
especially at that age,
like six,
they are,
they're really suffer.
It's a crazy thing how human beings just a lot of times really desire that
nuclear household and father,
mother household.
So much so that people will go through it.
And that's the other,
the other side of it is that the folks that go through it where they're just
getting tortured,
they hate each other,
but they're sticking together for the kids.
Like,
man,
you'd probably be better off.
The kids would probably be better off.
Plenty of families that shouldn't be together,
man.
It's so toxic.
And the kids grow up with the,
you know,
in that toxic environment.
But what you were saying before,
a kids do emulate what you do and by being a good example,
by taking care of your health and taking time to work out and pursuing your own
interests and not just making everything about the kid,
about the kid,
about the family,
you know?
Yeah.
You also give them a sense of independence too.
Well,
yeah.
Then they can see,
wow,
okay my,
my dad's his own man or my mom's,
her own woman and you know,
they're,
they're not just all wrapped up in me,
you know,
so what a,
what go,
what a great role
model that is for them to grow up and realize that yeah.
That that's the way it is.
Is there an age where kids shouldn't lift weights because we always heard that
when we were younger.
I'll give you a lift weights.
When you're a certain age,
it's bad for your body that it's bad,
it'll stunt your growth.
You'd always hear like things like that.
Is that,
are those myths?
A lot of it is a myth.
Uh,
I mean obviously kids when they're small,
they don't have good motor control or but good motor skills.
So you know,
you don't want them hurting,
hurting themselves.
But certainly doing body weight exercises,
I mean your,
your daughter probably tries to emulate you already anyway.
You know,
when she sees daddy and his home gym or whatever,
she wants to do some pushups and stuff and that's,
that's fun.
Usually by the time a kid is old enough to start doing household chores and
helping around the house a little bit is a good time to get them into some type
of formal training.
But it gotta be somewhat fun.
You know,
Scott is,
everything is planned.
We talked about,
uh,
Hickson's a hidden in Jujitsu.
You know,
you can kind of do like hidden workouts and stuff.
Yeah,
chrome would joke around about it with no hidden pressure.
Pressure was real man.
It's death pressures and real.
But can you imagine growing up the son of the greatest Jujitsu fighter ever has
to be just on the block,
not in the neighborhood,
not in the state,
not a state Chai.
Highest expression of the art that there ever was crazy yoga guy too.
And you know,
this dude is doing this crazy breathwork and shit,
whatever.
But also look,
look where it turned out.
I mean he's a world champion himself,
so obviously,
so something worked out there.
Clearly worked out with my kid.
You know,
I used to play all sorts of fun little games I would take.
He used to love to go to this dollar store,
you know,
everything was a buck and it was a a heaven for little kids,
all that cheap plastic toys and all that stuff.
So I'm a tape dollar bills up on a pole or on the wall and he would have to
figure out how to Pau furniture up and climb up.
And she does that tough like a fucking recipe for disaster.
You know,
I was spotting him,
you know,
but I mean he got good at climate stuff,
man.
Uh,
I used to bet him that he couldn't go from the basement of our four story
brownstone and Philly from the basement to the top for where my bedroom was
without touching the stairs.
So here's dealing like Ninja warrior stuff,
like bracing himself in the wall and are walking with his feeding one wall in
his hands and the other cat crawling up the railing and mean he was doing this
stuff when he was really,
really little.
And,
but,
but when he was like,
in kindergarten,
we play Indiana Jones and the temple of doom.
I'd have a big stability ball,
like the big uh,
concrete ball or you know,
the granite ball that,
uh,
there's going to crush Indiana Jones was Zack could jump down a flight of stairs
and land in role before I could roll that ball down the stairs and jumped down a
flight of stairs.
He learned to do this stuff from a very young age because he started when he was
like three or four years old.
How many stairs?
I'd be like 14 steps.
He jumped down,
he 14 you can hold onto the rail and swing his legs out and jump to the Oh,
okay.
So he would hold onto the rail and jump over time kind of,
no,
no.
He would like swing his body in the stairwell and jumped down a flight of
stairs.
Oh my God.
Eh?
He's kind of cool.
Yeah.
That seems like a lot of stress on the,
on your legs though.
Hey,
you know,
kids of that age,
they're so resilient and he had been built into this stuff.
You have from the time he was,
I bored,
man.
I was,
I was thinking that the other day when I was watching their kids play,
I was like,
you're very rarely hear about kids getting a knee injury that kids don't get
hurt.
I mean the film,
you know what,
you know when they start getting hurt,
when the parents start to put that fear of ground engagement anywhere in the
world,
you go buy a playground.
And I don't even have to understand the language to know what these people are
saying,
mothers and so forth.
Get Down,
look out,
right?
You're going to get hurt.
All that.
So dangerous gets it.
You know,
he put this fear,
the kids' minds.
But up to that point,
the body is so resilient.
Okay,
maybe they'll fall.
They start to learn their own limitations.
But instead,
well meaning,
but misguided adult put these limitations in their mind already premature.
So they never really discover.
So they get this inborn fear,
especially of falling and so forth.
One of the five big human fears,
you know,
and when I used to teach wrestling and Jiu Jitsu and so forth,
teaching people throws,
it was really hard as an adult because they had this terrible fear of falling.
But it was misguided because,
I mean,
when you're a little kid and you learn how to fall and wall exacted,
man,
you can take falls and throws and you're,
you're absolutely fine.
Bodies is so mobile,
so resilient.
They haven't built up all that stiffness.
But when you put that fear in a person's mind,
you get that fear reactivity for sure.
You're going to get hurt because you step in if the wrong time.
You know the difference between like dropping a ball on the ground and a brick,
you know,
the brick shatters and the ball will bounce.
Well,
he would make people like bricks with all this fearfulness and you hear it all
the time.
I hear parents constantly putting this,
this fear,
well,
I fell off a monkey bars when I was six and snapped my arm in half.
So it's probably good to have a little bit of fear.
I was like,
I broke my arm and my mom would always hear me say I broke my arm when I didn't
break my arm.
But she looked at me and she goes,
wow,
you really broke your arm.
Really did break your house,
snapped in half.
It was,
hey,
you know,
you learn a harsh lesson.
You know,
it still didn't make you completely afraid of climbing and doing stuff.
I mean,
I bet you within a couple months,
you right back in there and doing this stuff again.
Yeah.
Actually I remember falling out of trees.
It felt like every bone in my body broken.
You know?
You know what's amazing is,
um,
how well kids can manipulate their body to my,
my daughter can do a,
what is that called?
When you put your feet on the ground,
your back bends and you put your hand.
Yeah,
right there.
Little spies are so incredibly flexible and you know,
and she can go up on their tippy toes and she's only six.
She can also climb a rope.
I have a rope in my garage.
You see my garage is pretty fast.
The great,
she grabs that rope and climbs all the way to the top.
And I was watching her do that.
I was like,
how many women can do that?
Like she's a tiny little girl.
She's six.
Like how many grown women can support their own weight like that and climb up.
Most grown men can't do it.
No.
Most.
Yeah.
Most grown men,
they couldn't climb a rope if their life depended on it.
Yeah.
And that's sad.
It is sad and that,
that's one of the best things I ever did for my kid.
I just hung a rope in our foyer of our house.
We had like one of those cargo architecturally designed houses that the kitchen
went up three fours,
you know,
with uh,
like a uh,
uh,
by level type thing,
split level.
And uh,
took my life in my own hands with my drill.
Tried to hang that damn rope man.
I tied myself a with my Jujitsu about and was leaning over the back and he tried
to find a,
a beam with a beam finder and the,
you know,
got the drill.
This is all while they actually wife was out of the house.
She comes home,
she has this rope hang it down in the middle of her foyer by our kitchen.
And uh,
you know,
I got both kids climbing.
That rope is at the beginning of the divorce proceedings.
My whole,
from the moment I said I do was the beginning of the divorce proceedings.
That's how it works.
Sometimes it's just the idea of getting married,
let's,
we're going to be normal.
We're going to be like everybody else.
We're going to get married.
Well,
it'll work out once we're married or workout.
It never does,
man.
I preferred and marriage,
right.
And unmarried is where I have my money.
She has hers,
I got my credit cards.
She has hers.
I have my possessions.
I don't tell her what to do.
She doesn't tell me what to do.
You know,
it's like an agreement.
We're together because we want to be together.
We don't need a government agency to tell us that we can live together and we
definitely don't need a government agency telling us that we're allowed to be a
partner.
Well,
that doesn't sound very romantic style.
I don't know what kind of woman's can accept that,
but I'll tell you right now,
I am not going to,
I'll tell you right now,
Steve,
I want a traditional marriage.
I,
we won't
be able to tell my friends that I'm married.
That's the other thing.
Chicks love to tell.
Their friends are married.
Very few guys like you're excited to tell their friends they're getting married.
Like,
see,
I got her,
she's marrying me.
I did it.
You know,
they go,
Yay,
we're good.
We're getting married.
Like,
well congratulations.
But it's never like this milestone accomplishment.
Like wow,
you pulled it off.
But a girl will like,
look,
I'm getting like,
oh my God,
I can't believe in girls.
Get so excited.
I'm so happy for you.
They'll hug.
It's a two complete different experience for the male.
Women have got it in their head or some,
I should say,
because of movies and the stories.
You know this romantic happily ever after idea that they have to,
they have to get legally bound.
They don't think of it as,
you know,
it's you.
The way you look at it is so harsh and so jaded.
It's not a legal contract.
It's,
it's a beautiful agreement and it's you take your relationship to a next level.
Yeah.
Until you hit those divorce proceedings,
then you realize,
oh,
this is a contract.
Like this is a legal contract with the state and now I've got to bring in
lawyers and we've got to figure out how to fucking divvy up my money and the
lawyers get a Gi in chunk of that action.
That's the big scam.
That's when I'm Phil Hartman,
before his wife killed him,
when he was trying to get divorced,
shot him in his sleep.
He was ranting to me by go just fucking give her half and he's like,
it's not a half.
That's the thing.
It's a third because the lawyers get a third too.
You'll lose two thirds.
It's not half pretty much man.
It was just steaming out.
I liked the non marriage,
you know,
that's nice to non marriage and keeps their own personality and you don't like
just get all wrapped up.
See this Guy Jamie was showing me these yesterday's Russian oligarch.
Oh 4.5 billion EDI in a divorce.
Of course.
I guess when you have billions and billions is probably not that big of a deal.
It's a big deal.
No matter how much money you got,
the idea that some chick is going to be going off bang other dudes with your
money and ride and Ferrari's and flying private jets everywhere and buying
castles all with your cash.
Why?
Because he had sex with her.
I guess they don't have prenups and Russia or if they do,
he didn't get one.
I mean he's just maybe thought he was going to make,
this is going to be different man.
Fuck all the other 50% of the people that could make it.
I'm not even hedging my bets.
I'm all in.
He pushed all his chips on the table.
And you know,
the thing that,
uh,
I think sours a lot of marriages and I can speak from experience because I've
been married and divorced three times,
three times,
you know,
fucking crazy,
man,
man.
I keep going back for more.
And I finally got smart,
you know,
I think pretty crazy.
But so many of us guys,
we,
we get,
we get the,
uh,
a woman who was the,
what I call it,
the girl,
you know,
really fun to be around very,
feminine,
uh,
just you relate to,
together as friends.
And then what do we do?
We turn around and change her into a mother,
you know,
and mother is a whole different animal,
a whole different big than that girl that,
that,
that young girl that was carefree and fun to be around.
And you'd go to the movies and you'd go out and you'd play and you'd just have a
great time and all that just goes right out the window once you turn her into a
mother.
I'm not even talking about kids.
You know,
I've seen plenty of people without kids.
The woman's still becomes the mother.
Oh yeah.
You know,
like a mother substitute.
Will they become a dominant role in the man's decision making and they sort of
Cook,
Cook control him in a very motherly way.
I think that becomes very unattractive to women too.
Like I don't think a lot of women like that man,
they don't like that role.
I mean they didn't want to be put into that role.
You know,
a lot of women,
you know,
they,
they'd like a strong guy that kind of take care of them.
Right.
Well I don't know,
I mean I wouldn't want to generalize,
but I the the,
what I've seen from the women
that dominate the men,
the like the guys that I know where the woman tells him what to do.
And those guys also have a hard time getting sex.
Like almost universally,
it's almost,
it's almost like a rule.
Like if the woman dominates and the woman tells you what to do and the woman
does control your spending and controls,
you know what your hobbies are.
And tells you what's going to happen and where you're going to go.
Those guys don't care much sex.
And I don't know if that's related to like a woman being attracted to a man that
she can't control or not attracted to a man she can control rather
well.
The mother doesn't like sex.
The mother is against sex.
And that's what happens so often in these marriages.
And you know,
I've had a lot of women that are Massachusetts and you know,
the uh,
bodyworkers and man when,
you know,
they tell me it's uncanny how many of their male clients will always proposition
and tried to rankle sex out of them.
He's a legitimate anywhere.
I'm not talking about prostitutes.
Right,
right,
right.
And I mean,
it's pretty common.
Yeah.
Guys are just sex starved and their relationships and their,
their marriages.
But the thing that really used to rankle me most more than anything was the way
women would not want to be.
They would want to separate their guys from their,
their,
their friends.
And they really resented the fact that God is come to Shiatsu training as a guy
that owns it.
You.
She's at school,
man,
the,
the wives and girlfriends would give the guys such a hard time about gone and
train it.
If anything,
they should be encouraged and they got to go as much as possible and you know,
they pulled these guys out of there and that's a damn shame to do that to a guy.
It's also a damn shame for a guy to pull his woman out of something that she
loves to do.
Oh,
well yeah,
of course.
I mean,
to be fair,
of course.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a terrible thing when people try to change the person who they're,
they love and control them.
I mean,
could you imagine your friend doing that to you?
Like a friend going,
come on man,
you're not going to work out.
What are you working out for?
I don't want you working out.
Hey,
You're my friend.
You're coming with me.
You're like,
what?
Like,
I don't like you camping.
Why you camping?
You know,
I don't like you going to ballgames.
He'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You're crazy.
But when that friend happens to be someone that you have sex with or you
romantically connected to my girlfriend,
fiance,
wife,
whatever you want to call it,
that person all of a sudden has a some sort of a,
a role they can dictate like your actual day,
like dictate what you do,
whether it's a guy doing it to a wife or a girlfriend or a woman doing it to her
husband or her boyfriend.
It's a weird thing that people just sort of accept
I ed and it happens so often and it's always gross.
No wonder that divorces at its all time highest,
right.
Fucking idiots.
All of us.
I did it three times.
Did you think about on number three when that one failed,
would you like,
motherfucker,
what's wrong with me?
Why don't I do this three times?
Pretty much.
It was like,
damn,
I had a lot of shame actually and a lot of feelings of
unworthiness or whatever.
You know?
I like the feeling of being a failure and all that and then I just realized,
well,
you know,
some people just aren't cut out.
I should have never been in that situation.
The first point,
which wife did you have the kids with?
Uh,
the first one we held the third one.
Oh Wow.
So you had kids with both of them?
Yeah.
Ooh.
So how was,
how old's your oldest kid right now?
A 45.
Jesus Christ.
You got to 45.
I was 17 years old.
Wow.
Pretty much knucklehead,
you know.
So what would that make her?
That would be a,
well,
she gotta be like 45.
Wow,
that's crazy.
And then Zack blackbelt teacher down at a boiler,
Gracie school and Hedges Laboratory.
And um,
where's that at on Friday?
That's a Gracie San Diego.
San Diego.
Yeah.
They just moved into new,
I haven't even seen their new,
their new school yet.
The hedges just moved into a new place and especially to be fantastic.
What a hotbed.
San Diego was for training and his partner was this guy,
Joe [inaudible].
Johnny Fredda.
He's one of us nationals and World Nogi.
Think you went up at Dobie?
I don't know.
He's held,
uh,
Nogi grappler and Zach teachers for those guys down there.
And then boiler Glenn's the name to the school when it shows up,
you know,
I mean he's on the road most of the time and so forth.
Hoist is kind of done that too,
right?
Neither one of those guys,
they just decided to not have an academy.
Yeah,
it's,
it's hard being tied down to academy and it's better just to have like maybe a
place where you can,
you know,
let someone else run it and then you can go out in the road and to get the
seminar circuit.
And there's still a lot of call for a seminar.
Circuit is a big thing for venture to guys.
Eddie Bravo,
it makes a lot of money doing that.
That's a big part of his income.
He does a lot of travel and a lot of seminars and even myself,
I mean I get a fair share of Jiu Jitsu calls these days.
I mean,
you know,
I was one of the first American black belts and so forth.
Uh,
I don't consider myself an expert in the type of competition game they have now.
But when it comes to the old school self defense,
the Elliot Gracie self defense,
I kids just sit in myself,
one of the top authorities.
I learned it really well from both [inaudible] and Helson Elio himself and uh,
it's a fantastic system.
It's shocking how many black belts don't even know the basic standup self
defense.
They don't realize what a great self defense system Brazilian Jiu Jitsu really
is.
What do you mean by like standup self defense?
You fight starts standing it up right PB and grabbed you and bear hugs and
grabbing me by the hair,
by the throat or grabbing your jacket or pushing you up against a parked car or
wall.
There are self defense systems in place to either prevent those things or to get
yourself out of a bad situation.
It doesn't always involve going into the ground per sec.
And Elliot Gracie was a real master at adapting gold Japanese system and make it
more applicable to smaller,
weaker people with through the use of leverage.
And it can even be taught to kids.
It's a,
the grades you have that anti bullying system two,
which was the finest thing you can teach a kid.
I mean,
think about karate or taekwondo or whatever.
There are a lot of parents take the kids to,
how's that work?
Well,
you got to basically bust somebody in the face,
right?
Yeah.
You kicked him in the head or you know,
that's going to get you thrown out of school for sure.
Right.
But at least with Jujitsu,
you know,
you can use other means that isn't,
this is not going to get you suspended from school for,
you know,
two or three or four weeks or whatever.
I was watching,
um,
one of the,
uh,
inside the UFC ultimate insider's yesterday.
You know,
they have those shows where they detailed training camps and stuff and they were
talking about Tj Dillashaw.
I was preparing for this fight and they had a scroll at the bottom of the screen
and it was about a football player who got,
was under arrest for kicking another football player in the head and the other
guy was in critical condition.
Did you hear about that?
Man?
I don't know what it was is on the field or in the locker room or no idea.
It was just the scroll at the bottom and that the player was in critical
condition and then one one player kicked him in the head.
I don't know if it was pro or college.
I don't know what it was.
You know?
Well we have a very litigious society.
So you use a real violent way to,
to end some type of altercation.
Well,
you know,
you mentioned like the,
the,
the truck drivers today,
it was blocking you when you pick up your packages.
Yeah.
Imagine that went south and he started getting really belligerent and getting up
in your face may be portion around,
right.
Jujitsu would have enabled you to control the situation without necessarily
hurting the guy.
Right.
But if you would have resorted to your Muy Thai and I've seen the way you kick
and punch,
it's pretty formidable.
You couldn't knock the guy and the next week,
well you can really kill somebody.
That's the real problem with the prowl down,
killing,
killing people in fights.
A lot of times happens when you hit them and they go unconscious and they hit
their head.
Hit that on the ground.
Now imagine if you want to punch him in the face and he would have lost one
tooth.
I mean imagined of tooth replacement,
dental bill.
There's the thing Rutgers kicks Phillip Nelson off football team after
quarterback is charged and assault on Minnesota.
Man is,
that is crazy man.
The Minnesota guy was the linebacker for Minnesota state.
Is this,
they have a video of it?
Yeah.
Oh,
play the video.
Let's see this.
What happens here?
That's,
Oh man.
I wonder if they knew what the hell was going on.
Okay.
Fight that happened early Sunday morning as part of their,
everything's videotape now.
It's crazy.
Crazy.
Much not much privacy has been arrested and charged with assault.
Police released surveillance guys ruined his life man or a man was,
he certainly has it.
He was on the ground and being after being punched and knocked to the ground by
another session.
Oh,
it was a nightclub or something.
Former football on a set of statement.
Cato is in critical condition and doctors say that they're not sure he'll
survive.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So his life is ruined as he knew it.
Oh my God.
So he'll be out of school,
but they see that the point of,
you know,
using the violence and punching and kicking.
Yeah,
okay.
It works.
There's no,
Oh,
definitely
work.
But then after a fan,
don't you know,
the ramifications of using that type of violent behavior and for children in
particular to teach them that,
wow,
they're going to be thrown out of school for sure.
That that's why I was like the wrestling and the shoes yet.
So you can control it without necessarily to have to,
you know,
smash somebody.
Yeah,
they're absolutely.
The only real problem with that is of course multiple people,
but multiple people,
most of the time you're fucked no matter what,
pretty much.
It's very rare that a guy,
it's not like,
you know the movie Jackie Chan Movies,
Jackie Chan or sat them,
you know,
one video.
It was from Turkey where this guy was a boxer and he was being attacked by this
whole group of people we were doing.
We were watching it during one of the podcasts that we do and I was doing
commentary on it cause the guy is like really good boxer and all these people
were chasing after him and he's dropping them left and right.
This is like fucking 10 or 15 guys chasing after him and he drops like 10 of
them.
You know they're there,
circled around him and a guy comes forward,
crack.
He pops,
this guy crack,
he pops.
That guy,
they're trying to grab me.
He's backing up dropping guys.
It was really like a scene in a movie.
Like if you saw in the movie you would say,
well this is fun to watch,
but in real life this never happens.
But this actually did have,
she did it like that movie old boy.
Here it is.
Here's a video that they're chasing after this guy.
And so after they chased him out,
this guy,
they get out,
people started arguing and they're chasing after him.
But the guy knows how to fight.
Bam.
He drops that guy,
Bambi drops that guy,
Bam jumps that guy.
They're all chasing after him and now they're getting mad because he keeps
dropping these guys.
Look,
he's got his hands up,
he's got a good jab to check this Jab,
Jab,
drops,
that guy with a jab hook at this Bam.
That's just a stiff jab,
not,
and they're all running after him and he's moving back and he's got the state of
Missouri that drops,
that guy drops that guy.
He's got the,
the state of mind to,
to move back and then pause for a second and fire too.
Cause you guys come in there,
he's obviously trained.
Look at that jab tray.
Yeah.
Obviously hands up high and turning left and right and drop and dudes,
I guess,
I guess it seems like they're playing the same thing over and over again.
So it was probably only five or six guys,
but still,
well they're coming at them one at a time and obviously they weren't trained
people.
Yeah.
I think if you're,
you know,
imagine trying to fight train guys,
but you know,
how often do you ever find train guys out in the street and if you do what a
terrible situation,
that'd be a horrible situation.
But for the most part,
you know,
thugs aren't well trained.
I had a friend who got in an argument with a guy whether in their cars and
they're yelling at each other,
fuck you,
fuck you and pull over.
Fuck you.
And they put,
they pulled over and they both got out of the car and both guys could fight.
One got shot and the other guy,
the other guy stuffed it take down,
they start duking it out on their feet and they're like holy shit.
And they were both ways really about,
and he said we were going at it for like 10 minutes before.
Both of us are exhausted and they wound up high fiving each other and get back
in their car and drive it away.
Think they fucking both realize that like they were going,
they thought they were going to tee off on some dude.
He didn't know how to fight.
The guy shoots in for a double.
The other guys gets under hooks and sprawls and then looking at each other like,
what the fuck is going on here and there like faint and each other leg kicking
each other and shit.
They were actually duking it out and then somewhere along the line they were
having fun and they realize like they were having respect for each other and
then they high five each other and got back in their cars.
Why don't have the odd,
it's very rare.
Very,
very rare.
Also that they could go through that and laugh,
you know,
and go out.
It was fucking stupid.
Let's get out of here.
And you know,
bruised up.
It's always stupid,
right?
Oh,
always ends up being stupid.
Those type of things.
Well the worst is the drunken moments.
Like probably these guys that were at this nightclub is football player kicking
this guy while he's down the,
and also the crazy thing is movies that show head trauma and make it out like
it's no big deal.
I get pistol whipped and he wakes up later.
What happened?
Meanwhile,
he's fine,
you know,
and he's just still saving the day.
You know,
you get pistol whipped,
you probably fucked up for about six months and to be a serious concussion man.
Yeah.
I mean Matt Grice,
I don't know if you know who he is,
UFC fighter,
great guy was hit any collision was rear ended,
uh,
going 65 miles an hour.
Somebody just wasn't paying attention.
I don't know what the details were,
but his car,
his car was plowed into,
had brain surgery mean barely made it big scar on his head.
They had to remove his plate from his head.
They move a piece of his skull to give his uh,
his,
his brain of relief from the pressure and then they had to put it back in place.
But you know,
he was talking about how much it affects them,
how much mental fatigue he has.
Oh
God,
yes.
That creates,
like we were talking about it earlier,
you know,
like the NFL and the main focus,
they can cut the whole concussion controversy right now.
It's going to change.
Football's really not.
Yeah.
What are they going to do about that?
Because the sport,
it's like it all.
You're like MMA.
Like how would you take away the concussions?
Yeah.
I don't even know how that would happen.
You can't,
you know,
unless it would be some kind of like body shots only in wrestling or something.
But that,
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think the fans would buy it.
And the other thing that happens that you see in MMA is when a guy gets knocked
out,
how easy it is for him to get hurt after that.
Like Anderson Silva is a perfect example,
goes through his entire career.
It looks like it an a chain of iron,
you know,
fights.
Everybody never gets hurt.
Even if he gets dropped,
gets right back up.
Seems like he's fine,
you know,
fights all of these killers.
And then Chris Weidman shuts his lights out and then the next fight Chris
Weidman drops him with a punch that looks like he would absorb that punch under
any other circumstances.
If you look at these entire career,
it was hit with harder punches,
hit with cleaner punches,
seem to be fine,
but he takes that one shot from Weidman.
And he see his eyes roll back and he goes down,
he recovered,
he's hanging on for dear life and clenching.
But you got a sense that he's damaged as a human right.
You know,
the nervous system gets insulted like that and it just builds and builds and
builds.
I remember as a college wrestler my senior year,
I was illegally slammed on my head and had a pretty bad concussion.
And,
uh,
I had another incident in training,
same thing.
And they,
they,
they told me even back then,
and this is back in the 70s,
that one more.
I was banned for the season.
That was it.
Wow.
Yeah.
But not an MMA though.
So many guys get knocked out and training and then wind up fighting,
you know.
So a few more.
Eddie Alvarez just pulled out of his big fight with Michael Chandler and one of
the things that he was talking about was a,
that he had gotten knocked out before their last fight.
He got knocked out and training a few weeks before the fight and got through it.
Okay.
But that this one was,
uh,
he had gotten hit and training,
wrestling,
uh,
you know,
someone sprawled and he got hit in the head by when a guy used his hips and it
just a collision,
you know,
it's the random collision.
And then another random collision while he was trying to get a single,
the guy pulled his leg out and as the guys kicking his leg out,
he hit him on the Chin and you know,
thinks he's fine,
just training hard like normal but then can't get over the headaches and it just
like it hurts him to move his head around.
And then he goes to a neurologist and he needed to,
he gets cat scans done the whole deal and they realize like,
you know,
you're not going to be,
it's going to be very interesting to see what happens in these next 10 years
with the first crop of mixed martial arts fighters and how they age and what a,
you know,
some of these guys are getting a little bit older now and what the permanent
ramifications there going to be from all of those brain injuries and so forth.
And I think it's going to be similar to what we saw in boxing with a lot of
these guys,
you know,
having dementia and you know,
the,
the classic punch drunk.
It's,
it'd be interesting
I think I agree with you and I think that,
um,
it,
it kind of brings up the question that we're talking about with Dan Gable.
Like,
is that glory worth having those hip replacements?
There's one thing to have your body aching,
but it's another thing to have your mind compromise to the point where the
quality of your thinking has greatly deteriorated.
Not just your ability to move your body,
but your ability to communicate with people.
Like when you used to hear Joe Frazier before he died,
it was painful to listen.
I actually saw him out of the street,
you know,
cause I lived in Philly and I,
I asked,
you saw him walking down Passyunk avenue,
right where I live.
Papers said,
hey Joe.
And the poor guy,
he couldn't understand a word he said,
the way he swore his speech.
And it was like really,
really weird.
Sad.
Do you,
do you ever foresee in the future,
um,
remember how McCain was trying to band MMA for the longest time right after the
initial thing got started?
Do you think,
do you foresee any of that happening again as,
as this type of thing happens?
I'm just curious.
It could,
but it would be burying sod.
It would be,
the only way that would be possible is if someone figured out a way to make
football safe.
Because if they don't make football safe and they're not going to banned
football,
football's the national gas is too big a sport.
Too Big,
too huge.
Too many people love it.
Too many people look forward to at football.
Season's just a huge part of being American.
Um,
if they don't ban that and someone wants a band MMA,
it's going to be a real problem.
She's going to be hard to reconcile.
But you know,
they say that,
well,
the difference is that football,
the goal is not to knock a man unconscious.
The goal is to get a ball across the line to score.
Correct.
Sort of like organized team warfare.
Yeah.
That's all well and good,
but what's happening?
What is actually happening?
What's actually happening is giant people are slamming into each other.
And one of the things that this guy told me,
um,
that I found incredibly fascinating about concussions.
He's like,
the big misconception about concussions is that it has to be from head injury.
well you don't realize is you can get a concussion from getting hit in the
chest.
Oh yeah.
A hard shot to the chest.
Like football players colliding with each other.
Not even making contact with the head,
but just the,
the boom,
the impact of these enormous ball or full body slamming into each other causes
the brain to rattle around inside your squash up against the side of the brain
path.
And that causes concussions.
And there's was a lot of guys who suffer concussions with no head trauma.
Their head doesn't actually get caught.
It's not a direct head contact.
They,
it's just the body getting rocked by an impact.
How are you,
how are you going to take that out of sports?
Any sport?
Even basketball guys fall down.
Combat Sports.
Yeah.
I mean,
one of the things that the guys can do this,
boom,
there's a perfect example,
Jamie.
That's that guy got a concussion.
That's right.
Watch this.
Look at this.
Look at his head.
Boom.
The way it snap.
Oh my goodness.
In the size of that man who grabbed him,
Jesus.
Louisa.
Like if you'd think about a guy like Lawrence Taylor going full clip or Ray
Lewis,
that it's just like a nightmare.
Ms guys can go a hundred yards in like sprinter time,
elite sprinter time,
and they're 300 pounds of muscle.
It's,
yeah,
it's shocking.
The forces that go in go into the whole thing,
by the way.
Not Possible without steroids.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
You don't get that big,
you know,
get that strong.
You don't get that fast.
Test them all you want.
There's some shit going on.
There's a lot of those fucking dudes that are on the juice.
If you go back in time and you look at the football players from the 1960s and
you look at the football players of today,
sure you had your guys,
you know you had,
yeah.
You had your,
your,
you,
you know,
who was the,
um,
the guy who was a,
who did a commentary in a UFC one,
Jim Brown,
super athletes,
super natural.
What I try to sever fantastic athlete.
[inaudible] guys today are so much bigger than him there just,
he's a little guy by their status back even further.
Let's take Jim Thorpe.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I went to gym.
I went to,
uh,
I grew up in Carlisle,
Pennsylvania.
Where Jim through,
I went to the Indian school there and Carlisle Pa,
no kin and I went to school with his,
uh,
his nephews,
his grandnephews.
Both boys were,
what was he like as he got older?
He became an alcoholic.
Unfortunately.
You know,
he was penniless.
He was stripped of his Olympic medals for playing a one pro baseball game or
something.
Getting paid for a game.
Yeah.
They had stripped his metals from him for the,
his amazing Olympic performance because he did the baseball game before the
Olympics or after the lump.
And I know before he had actually got paid like Medo nominal amount of money.
I don't know,
$15 and 700 for playing the game.
And he was stripped of his medals and,
but he had died a,
just basically a ditch digger and a pending list,
Scott.
But to give you an idea of how versatile football,
porous border in those days by,
uh,
my friend,
there's the nephew of Jim Thorpe told me it was a story that he missed the bus
from Carlisle to Harrisburg to play the game.
So he ran from Carlisle to Harrisburg,
which is about 18 and a half miles to the game and got there in time to play the
second half and scored several touchdowns.
How far is that?
18 miles.
Ran 18 miles.
Try Dog tried at 18 miles,
got there in time to play the second half and actually won a,
uh,
did a couple of scores.
Insane.
Talk about an insane athlete.
How big was he?
Uh,
you know,
I don't know,
bring it up.
It Jim Thorpe,
he wasn't a big guy,
but he,
you know,
they played both ways.
You know,
you played authentic and he played defense.
They'll look at that.
It looks like a UFC welterweight and he was a damn good boxer.
A wrestler too.
Wow.
And,
but I mean that was back in the day where they didn't suffer the terrible head
traumas because it was more of an arm grabbing wrestling kind of game.
And we're guys smaller too and smaller.
And you know,
I stayed in Sydney,
I love Australia,
I love the ozzies and up is teaching Jujitsu down there and they're really into
Australian rules football.
And it's very similar to rugby.
The guys don't get nearly the trauma traumatic injuries that they do.
And like NFL,
it's more like organized team wrestling.
They're out there wrestling and in fact they train a lot of wrestler wrestling
for these guys.
They bring wrestlers in to teach them basic wrestling holds.
And um,
you don't get the,
I think it's the modern equipment that allows these guys to hit each other with
such force.
Well that is the big argument about football that if you really wanted to make
football safe or you would take away the helmets and people are like,
that's so counterintuitive.
Like how,
how can you protect people by taking away protection?
But the reality is that protection is,
it's a fake sense of security.
The fake sense of security.
Take the gloves off the UFC fighters like he did in the first four.
You okay?
You're going to see a lot of surface cuts,
right?
You know,
facial cuts,
you know,
for the knuckles,
but you're not going to see the traumatic head injuries like you do with the
gloves.
There's gloves,
a lot of guys to punch.
So freaking hard that make the hands like weapons.
But you take the gloves off,
man,
the hands pretty fragile.
You're not going to just be granted a patent of like,
uh,
you know.
Do you think if they did that you'd start to see guys practicing on the Maki?
Wara remember those,
uh,
those Japanese probably would.
You'd have to definitely touch cheetahs.
Still does a lot of that still practices on
the,
I think you'd see a lot of open hand strikes as well.
I think you're right.
I remember when mom Hales,
Keith Hackney,
fuck that gigantic sumo dude and essentially bitch slapped him,
bitch slapped him,
dropped him.
The guy was like 600 pounds a manual Yarbrough,
he hit him with this gigantic like swinging bitch slap,
which is a great self defense techniques.
Your Palm,
it's amazing how much impact your palm can take and not get hurt.
I mean,
you could do that.
Look,
I'm doing this on this hard oak table.
If I did that with my knuckles it would fucking hurt.
Oh yeah.
And plus you know,
you,
you can so easily break your head by my,
uh,
my Jujitsu measure.
Helson Gracie was renounced street fighter in his own right and he used to
practice open hand techniques all the time.
He used to,
he call it slap in the bag so to speak.
And he,
he always taught us not to use closed fist in any type of realistic
confrontation.
Open hand strikes are quite effective for self defense.
Yeah,
you could certainly fuck somebody up.
The best example of that.
His boss Rutan rooting in pond Crace and palm Crace wine making a named pancreas
boss figured out boss has like really flexible risks in some way and he figured
out how to pull his hands.
His hands go like,
you see how my hand,
like if I was striking,
my hand goes out.
It's like sort of like not even 90 degrees,
not quite.
Bosses would go way back like this.
I don't know how the hell he did it when he stretched his wrists out,
probably did.
But when he was striking,
he was doing boxing techniques,
whereas in pancreas everybody else was kind of slapping and swinging.
Boss was throwing straight palm strikes and palm hooks,
so he was throwing them in a very traditional boxing way and knocking guys
senseless.
I just whomp technique,
incredible power behind his straight right palm technique,
you know,
he was a great puncher,
so he just pulled his hands back and threw punches,
but threw punches with his palm and was able to really date.
That was the thing about pancreas is like,
you know that they were,
we're not allowed to use closed fists on the ground they were using to the body,
but they were not allowed to use them on the face standing up or on the ground.
So everything had to be these kind of slabs.
But boss just throw the whole fucking system out of whack because he would just
crush guys with that.
Paul Pilcher,
Dan,
he's another guy that's in some serious pain right now.
He's got one atrophied arm,
his arm is a shriveled up and he's going through all these different treatments
to try to regenerate the nerves and the tissue in his,
in his arm.
So real sad.
And he's,
yeah,
I mean there's a hell of,
and no one ever said that these sports are healthy.
You know,
you do it cause you love it.
There's something inside you that makes you want to do it.
But,
uh,
you know,
I mean truth be known and grappling is something he could do pretty well and
advanced age by Leo was like 90 and they're still grappling is,
yeah,
it was like 95,
96.
Oh is he like rolling and right.
You rolled around with him right when he was,
it was that old.
He was amazing.
He liked to lay there and let you tried to do stuff to him.
He loved to play that game and it was like he could read your mind.
He already knew what you wanted to do before you even it.
But he moved well,
even though he's really,
oh wow.
He moved really,
really well.
He had hurt his knee jumping off the back of a truck and uh,
yeah,
so he,
he was so stiff in his knee,
but he was pretty mobile guy even in his nineties.
It was amazing how well he moved around.
What do you think about,
like there's,
there's techniques today that you're seeing in Jujitsu and MMA,
the,
all these Jujitsu techniques that,
um,
we're not in the original systems.
There's all these new found movements that some guys just don't want to adapt.
They don't want to incorporate them into their,
uh,
their strategy,
or into their game.
You know,
what do,
what do you think about that?
I,
I find that to be incredibly weird because Jujitsu itself was like this new
thing,
these new effective techniques that the folks that were originally learning them
didn't know.
You know,
Leo Gracie,
Carlos,
Gracie,
they take these techniques,
they modify them,
they make them even better.
So they essentially have this completely new system.
Well,
they brought it to America like especially in 1993 when the UFC came along,
that's what the whole thing was about.
It was about these new techniques that people couldn't defend against because
they weren't aware of them,
but now they don't incorporate new techniques into this system.
And the idea that it's perfect as is and then it can't be improved upon.
I think that's a little short sided and little weird considering how the system
started in the first place.
Well,
you have to think of it like this combat versus sport,
real fighting versus sport fighting the rules will dictate the techniques.
Just like taekwondo.
At one time it was a fairly formidable martial art but because once it became an
Olympic sport it just became so stylized at taekwondo must became useless as a
martial art take geared up.
For example,
the original judo was based in identical to Jujitsu but once it became an
Olympic sport and people started practicing it within the roles,
they became more and more stylized to the point where Judah lost any semblance
of being a real martial art that you could use for self defense.
So I think what the Gracie Jujitsu practitioners are saying is we don't want to
take some of these new found techniques and incorporate it in our style because
this is for sport only.
This is stuff that you would only do in the sport itself and that we want to
stay with the more traditional combat oriented techniques that have been tried
true and proven for for many,
many centuries.
Really,
if you think about it,
that being said,
my,
my son said something to me cause I,
I was kind of ragging on 50,
50 and bear and buffalo and he says,
yeah,
but pop,
if you don't know this stuff,
you're going to get your ass handed up to get by some guy that does.
So it's best to be familiar with all of this stuff.
So I thought that made an interesting point.
But you know,
when it comes to the UFC,
I mean obviously you're not going to bear on ball.
Oh somebody you're going to get your lights punched out or you know,
I'm not going to jump guard in the parking lot out here.
If something,
God would give me a hard time.
Right.
But if you do wind up scrambling,
you fall on the ground.
The guys on top of you,
the guard does work in a street fight.
Oh hell yeah.
Man,
I've Fed,
I can't tell you how many students in Philadelphia,
uh,
I,
my salad,
a few scrapes and blade,
it worked beautifully.
But once again,
we're not fighting trained fighters.
Yes.
You know,
we're not entering into a contract to put on the show and to fight each other.
Right.
You know what I mean by that logic like the guard,
you would never use the garden the street,
like why would you use the gardens?
Treat the guard.
Seems like something that you would use in a sport only.
I mean you're on your back.
Why would you ever put yourself in that position?
Only because it got flooded.
Exactly.
Because he had no choice but in that,
in that respect,
then the 50 50 which is for folks who don't know,
it's almost like a two guys going for heel hooks at the same time to set up
pretty much under locked leg position.
If you're in a situation where somehow or another in a mad scramble,
you wind up with a guy like that boy,
a heel hook in the fucking street would be absolutely devastating.
Well,
the guy who didn't know it happened,
chase you.
You could just walk away and he'd be Atlanta there.
Oh,
he'll look is one of the worst techniques ever as far as the going from like not
feeling any pain to irreparable damage or damage that you're going to have to
get surgery for.
It's like that.
Like the difference you don't have play or if you have a little bit of play in
an arm bar,
like here you're okay here.
You're like,
fuck,
I might have to tap tapping with a heels.
Look,
by the time it gives,
the things are ripping apart the injury cause you don't have set the sensory
nerves not well developed.
They heal the leg.
A lot of the leg locks were,
were originally Russian sambo.
Really?
Yeah.
They were very highly developed by the,
the,
the Russian sound bogus.
They had their own grappling style and the Gracies actually learned a lot of
these techniques and took,
took the song bow and embraced it and put it as part of Gracie Jujitsu.
The [inaudible] did an awful lot of that toe.
They studied samba.
They can paint it.
I actually saw a couple early Gracie videos of Hickson and John Shock and Hagan
competing in Samba Tournament's uh,
California.
And,
uh,
yeah,
it's real interesting.
This Russian guy beat both.
He beat two Machado's and then met Hickson in the finals and Hixson beat the guy
and,
and the finals.
The interesting.
Yeah,
it was real.
Real.
It really good.
This Russian guy is pretty good.
What's his name?
Ah,
man.
I don't know if this is years ago I saw this video.
This is an old footage that I saw in Jorge Office,
but at any rate they were made,
they were military technique.
If you maim to soldier maimed them,
then it would take at least two comrades to take him out.
So now you've put three people out of the picture.
Uh,
so they would rip apart the knees.
So now the guys all maimed and so now it takes at least two buddies to help get
the guy back.
So you put three people out of the fight with one maiming.
I said it's,
you know,
it's when,
oh,
here it is.
Is this a,
this might be,
it does that Hixon
on does John Jock,
there was a blonde Russian dude that was kicking everyone's ass.
And this one.
It's usually,
it's a tournament.
Oh yeah.
They're going after leg locks.
I as as the Sambas are devastating with this freaking legs,
man.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's all that.
Oh,
like chick Tara does.
John Joc though that that just did a John Jock in the blue.
I remember Hickson was wearing this.
You remember the color for shorts?
He was wearing the one,
the one tournament that I saw,
there was a blonde Russian guy that was pretty much kicking everyone's ass and
then a Hickson was wearing this,
a multicolored shorts that he was famous for that beach and beach fight in Rio
when he fought you go Duarte.
Yeah,
there's this is Hagen.
He getting in his day was a bad motherfucker.
All my guys still is probably.
Yeah.
I haven't seen in a way and he's a big guy now,
but yeah.
That's interesting.
That was very interesting.
How familiar are you with prolotherapy?
I don't know much about it or maybe I knew it by another name.
Proliferation therapy.
Prolotherapy is a,
the inject this glucose solution into joints into into ligaments and it actually
thickens the ligaments.
That's interesting because I have read a lot about the hydrochloric acid that
they inject into joints for osteoarthritis and so forth.
I think that it works on a similar way,
I think to a kind of hydrate the,
the connected tissue in there.
Um,
what I was bringing it up is because I knew a dude who,
uh,
used to get it done,
even though he didn't have injuries,
he would get it done on his elbows,
on his knees,
just to thicken up and strengthened the tag,
the tendons and ligaments,
just a for training because a,
apparently it can strengthen it as much as 40%.
Well,
that's pretty impressive.
That's very impressive.
Right?
Wow.
Yeah,
and they would,
it wouldn't you inject it.
It's really painful.
I had it done on my knee and I hadn't done on my wrist.
It did wonders for my wrist.
I broke my wrist when I was a kickboxing,
like in 1988 or 89 if fucked with me for a long time until I got this
prolotherapy on it and whatever it did,
it really wasn't right.
Yeah.
I mean,
it went away a little bit on its own.
It got better on its own,
but it would click all the time and it would just,
it would ache after I would train for a long time.
But this prolotherapy somehow or another,
by injecting it directly into the ligaments,
it forces the ligaments to swell and then stepped something sorta like the
hydraulic has it now.
There's these states tasted thick.
There's another therapy that a lot of people don't know of.
But back in the 70s,
it was huge.
It's the Dso,
dimethyl sulfur oxide.
Uh,
I'm a big advocate of this stuff and you can still buy it.
And some health food stores.
Why did they stop selling that?
Well,
the FDA at one point wanted the big pharma companies can't make any money on it.
They can't do it in the patent.
And this is about the time when all the nonsteroidal anti inflammatory drugs,
you know,
like I per profit or Advil or whatever,
it was coming into play.
So they put the Chi Bosch in this stuff and got them to ban it.
And then at some point,
I guess the ban lifted or whatever and it became popular again.
But I,
I remember like hearing like some of my age had aunts
and uncles talking to me about dms.
Oh.
When as a kid and wow,
this stuff works and it works well and uh,
yeah,
it's like for horses,
right?
Yeah.
They used to use it as a limit for race horses and you put it topically on the
skin and has this unique property of sinking right through into the connective
tissues and it has an amazing antiinflammatory effect at a,
really helps the body,
uh,
with its own healing process.
Yeah.
I remember guys used to use it back in the,
uh,
the taekwondo days when they would get injuries to their feet,
like kicking things,
kick elbows and stuff like that.
Guys would rub it on their feet and their shins.
Things along those lines.
Yeah,
I,
I'm using it now.
I hadn't used it for years,
but I decided to try it again.
I've been putting on the shoulder had been bothering me and wow.
I can't believe it's just one week.
How much better the shoulder feels,
more pain free.
That has been in a while and it,
which makes me wonder why I wasn't doing it early,
but say when I was doing it before I was still doing the kettlebell snatches and
I become a,
a bit of a critic about the Kettlebell snatch as an exercise.
I think it puts an awful lot of trauma on the wrist,
elbow,
and shoulder for no good reason.
You know,
people say,
oh,
the snatches depending ultimate left and Kettlebell,
the and all this and that.
Man,
I can't tell you how many people I've seen injured themselves.
I'm not talking about people using crappy technique using the technique,
you know,
really good technique and still suffering,
osteoarthritis and rheumatoid problems.
I mean,
you think about it,
you take a heavy weight and you continuously throw it over your head
continuously over time.
And of course you're going to get repeated trauma.
What about presses?
No precedent.
Fantastic.
So you think that,
what is the,
about the motion while you're swinging this kettlebell overhead and it suddenly
stops and you get all this,
this uh,
loading of the,
the connective tissues at the top,
it's like a dead stop.
The momentum and you know,
I mean there's always people that can seem to seem to waltz through life doing
these type of lips and so forth.
But yeah,
it seems to skate through it.
But man,
there's thousands of people that suffer and I think all of the benefits of the
snatch can be certainly had in the swing.
You don't need to,
to traumatize your shoulders in order to get benefits from,
from the kettle,
the swing where it stays horizontal.
Yeah,
exactly.
There's a momentum just dies out.
It's all,
it's all hip and button,
hamstrings lower back and you've,
you know,
you've generated the force.
So,
you know,
for me,
I was really into the snatch thing for longest time,
but it was definitely a traumatizing my shoulder.
What other exercises do you think maybe should be avoided?
Kettlebell exercise.
I'm beginning to think that the windmill with really heavy weights is it should
be avoided.
That's really,
yeah.
I mean I'm not talking about like just doing it with lighter weights,
but some of these guys,
you know,
they're,
they're into 40 kilogram kit.
Uh,
Ken about that's the 90 pounds.
what is it,
like 88 pounds?
I think that's pretty,
yeah,
they
are needed to subject your,
your body.
It's like a rotation and a twist.
The spine.
So you gotta be really careful with the,
when you're loading up these,
these type of Flexi bendy postures like that.
A lot of the overhead squat stuff,
I mean,
you know,
just cause he can discuss,
you can do it doesn't mean you should,
you know,
I was going to,
a guy was saying that a for shoulder stability,
that it's really great one because of the fact that it's got all this twist to
it.
You know,
that you're,
I mean the getup is going to get all that everything the window does to kind of
get us even better.
Plus you get the benefit of moving your body from the ground,
standing up and back down and so forth.
The window has a weird sort of hamstring thing going on with it though.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Because I get a lot of hamstring soreness when I do heavy windows.
But yeah,
you're,
you're lengthening of the hamstrings out really good.
So it's,
you know,
quite a severe stretch,
like a form of gloated stretching or weighted stretching and so forth.
But I mean,
if you're really,
if you're really wanting to get down to brass tacks,
if you're pretty much just doing getups and swings,
you pretty much had the perfect workout right there.
You don't need a whole lot else.
Just get up swings.
What about presses?
Well,
presses are always a good thing,
but I mean,
he can do presses,
but anyway,
right,
you can do handstand pushups,
you can do dumbbell barbell.
But yeah,
kettlebell about presses a fantastic exercise.
There's no doubt about it.
And I think the,
uh,
Kate about double front squat is a beautiful way to squat.
Um,
the,
the double front squat where you claim two kettlebells and you hold it in what's
referred to this as the rack position and do squats.
It's a really user friendly way of doing it.
That's what I do.
All My,
my squats that I do with weights,
I do them all that way.
I was using the squat rack,
but I felt like it's harder to do it this way and I feel like I'm engaging my
core more because I'm keeping him in front of me.
Absolutely.
I,
your posture has to be correct to do it.
So I just went with all of them and I just do with two seventies,
I just use to 70 and my age now.
I see no reason to.
My sister's right there to load my spine up with a really,
really my friend Mike Waller,
he was a strong dude.
Oh my God.
Mike is ridiculously so,
and a Vegan to anyone that thinks you can't be strong and be a Vegan.
Just check out Mike.
Ridiculously strong and Vegan for,
I mean he's,
you know,
he's really dedicated your whole lifestyle of being in a vacant and very
knowledgeable and not even annoying about it then.
No,
not at all.
Now he doesn't push his agenda whatsoever.
No,
it's great.
If anything people ask him.
Yeah.
Well you are,
um,
your website.
What do you have on there as far as,
I know that you develop,
uh,
you have like people that you train online,
you develop programs for them.
I go,
how does that work and how could someone sign up for that?
Well,
I called up my freedom business because I could do it pretty much anywhere in
the world.
That's one reason why I'm able to keep up my nomadic existence because,
you know,
as long as I have Wifi,
I'm good to go.
I still have the 62 liter drum or whatever.
They'll say she five liter spray bag.
Yeah.
By my girlfriend's beat me now.
She just down downsize
to a 45 later.
She said,
dammit.
Since when to,
you know,
you have a,
a woman traveling with less stuff than a guy.
That's ridiculous.
Of course I have workout equipment in my bag.
So,
uh,
well there you go.
Abdominal wheel rubber band suspension.
Keep an AB wheel with you.
Out of all the things you can keep with you and ab wheel is that important?
They decided
I like it.
You know what I mean?
It's so light and you know,
and I used the I a motto,
a task with it,
the little,
the little bar that you use for it.
I use it with my rubber band to do rubber band,
Desert Wilson.
Such a cool stuff he can do with that,
with that little handle.
You,
you uh,
you showed me a bunch of stuff that you could do in hotel rooms.
Like you throw a towel over it
door.
Oh Hey chin ups off the door.
Oh,
you're really truly need is just your body weight.
I just carry this stuff around cause I can,
but maybe I was dump it and go even warm and it was like a,
like Teresa,
you know.
So how do you,
when you,
uh,
develop these programs for someone,
say I'm a,
I'm Jamie over here who,
uh,
likes to exercise.
If you,
uh,
wanted to,
build a,
a program for someone,
what do you,
do you let them fill out a form?
How active are you?
How in shape?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
first of all,
I want to make sure that I can help the gut.
There's no sense of him wasting his time or money or may wasting my time with
the guy that I can't help.
So it sends me a little bio what it is he's interested in.
It gives me a chance to see if the guy has realistic goals and ideas.
And if he's like way out there,
you know,
maybe he'd be better off going to somebody else.
But if he's pretty much in line with what I think I can do as far as helping the
guy,
the next step then is I send them a questionnaire,
which is extensive lifestyle questionnaire.
Everything from you know your work too.
You know,
I almost like that era.
Vedic tests you took,
you know,
I want to know.
And then he sends me a diet log.
I want to see what he's putting in his body and then I send a fitness
assessment.
In the meantime he takes three photos.
No unposed just like in a pair of shorts.
So I can look at this structure.
I particularly need to see the feet and the knees and see how the guy standing,
his posture,
you know,
uh,
back front side.
So I need to look at his spine,
his shoulders and looking for is any structural stuff going on.
And based on those photos,
sometimes I'll have different fitness assessments cause before I can take him
where he thinks he wants to go,
I got to know where he's at.
Do you watch him do a video?
Do you like make I sometimes,
yeah,
sometimes.
But for the most part,
you know it's unnecessary.
Once he does this fitness assessment,
I have a really good handle on where he's at and then I'll send them a program
and then he sends a training log in anywhere between once a week to some people
are like to send something every day and they have recovery days after recovery
days as long as uh,
as well as their workouts.
A lot of the guys that are participating in Jujitsu,
some guys are participating in MMA,
but a lot of the guys are just regular guys,
businessmen,
business women,
housewives.
They just want to be healthy.
How many clients do you have that you do with?
Right now I haven't counted,
but it's close to 60 I know there's a lot of time on that.
A lot of hours a day,
man.
How many hours a day do you do that for?
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't track cause it's different each day.
Some days it's like six,
eight hours.
Other days it's like three or four.
Depends on how many logs to come in.
But I tried to have a turnaround time of never more than 24 hours.
But it's all you.
It's just me.
So you don't ever go on vacation,
like you don't say,
Hey,
I'm taking a week off for life.
Yeah.
Wow.
But I like it.
Say it's different.
So your life is kind of a big question.
Anything.
I'll be like,
I'm leaving from here to Ikaria Greece.
Whoa.
In the GNC off the coast of Turkey.
Beautiful,
pristine little quiet island.
A lot of people never heard him.
And uh,
it's named after the mythological figure,
Icarus that flew too close to the sun with his wings and plunged into the ocean.
His wings melted or something.
Wings melted.
Well,
this,
uh,
island,
uncle had to be there for three weeks doing it like a lifestyle training camp
and the Wifi is a little sketchy,
but uh,
I'll be okay.
So I'll be doing my iPad while looking out at the beautiful blue a GNC or uh,
you know,
I was in a high rise in Sydney.
You're looking out over the harbor.
So it's,
you know,
it's pretty easy to do your work when you pick really nice places like that.
So when you,
plus I love donuts so it's not like a chore or anything.
It's,
I really enjoy communicating with these people and I,
you know,
you almost become friends,
you,
you kind of sometimes like I'll meet them at seminars,
which is always really cold,
you know,
to,
to actually meet the person.
But you really develop a closeness and a camaraderie through the,
through the emails.
That's interesting.
When you go to a place where they speak a different language,
do you have a translator?
Like how do you,
how do you have a universe?
Like I just got back from Russia not too long ago.
I was in Novosibirsk,
that's the very heart of Russia.
Remember that Guy Alexander Karelin?
Yes.
He,
that's where he's from.
It's what a scary fuck that guy,
that guy up Alexandra [inaudible] amazing photos.
Most of crazy,
scariest Reza.
People would turn themselves over and pinned themselves.
So not to be thrown with his patented gut wrenched throw.
There would be fee belly down and he would get his hands underneath them and
take a 250 pound man and he was like,
like nothing and smashed them under the ground.
So there is in Novosibirsk the Russian experiment,
he uh,
no one spoke any English whatsoever.
So I have a universal translator,
my iPad and iPhone that I can
write a question down and then show it in Russian and then hit a button and
change the keyboard to Russian and then they can type back and be in English so
you can communicate with this modern technology.
That's crazy though.
But like what if you want to get something eat or you want
to get a room in a hotel or something like that?
Yeah,
well usually we'll go to them.
Usually hotel personnel do sound one there speaks English.
That's one of the nice things about being a u s citizen.
I mean I,
there's a lot of things I don't like about this country but it's still a super
power and it's still,
you know,
the,
the countries so to speak.
So most people speak English in these,
in these hotels because tourism is a real big thing for a lot of these places.
That's so fascinating that you do though.
You go from one place or another like that with no stops.
Like you don't watch none because you're living out of this 65 liter bag,
everything.
I,
you don't really have a place where you like,
well we're done work.
We're going to just hang out at home for a few days.
You don't,
there is no hope everywhere.
I'm at his home.
Do you foresee that for the rest of your life?
I mean,
you're 62 now.
Is that what you are at a 61 61 one and a half.
Give you an extra year there.
61 and a half like a kid.
I could a kid.
Um,
do you,
do you foresee living the rest of your life like that?
Yeah,
I mean,
I enjoy it that much.
really nice not to be tied down.
Once you get that,
that roaming spirit,
I can't even imagine
to settle it down.
But what about your body?
I mean you're,
you're essentially teaching people health and physical fitness.
How long do you think you'll be able to do that for at 61 years old?
That's a very unusual to,
for someone to be teaching people how to lift weights and exercise.
And I mean,
I've seen some of the shit that you've done.
Somebody posted a video of you working out with those guys that do the round
workouts,
which is an incredible,
those guys I got a year ago,
man,
that was,
the guys are so fit.
I mean,
it stays,
it's amazing watching some of those playground workouts that those guys do.
Urban gymnastics.
Yeah.
They have no legs though.
You ever notice that little skinny ass fucking toothpick legs.
The other thing too,
a lot of these guys are
or hurt a lot.
You know,
it puts a lot of stress in your body,
right?
It's not necessarily the kind of thing that you'd want to do,
but I mean,
it's amazing how these guys,
I mean essentially they're just doing this for their own fun,
right?
I mean,
they lobbied fabs,
will they,
that that is incredible as a stone dude.
Huh?
It's that guy can put his legs up there in the air.
What do they do for their lower Bonnie though?
There's so much upper body stuff and all these exercises.
You very rarely see them doing lower bodies.
Yeah.
She has actually said,
ah,
you know what they did for the lower body.
But uh,
I mean for sure what they do is pretty amazing,
but might not be the best way to go for especially people over 40 because the
joint trauma,
you know,
cause remember there's the difference between working for strength and
demonstrating strain and doing feats and stents versus just regular exercise.
And it's Thompson feeds to take its toll over time.
You know,
like Olympic lifting,
power lifting,
those guys are pretty bogged up by the time they get to their forties or 50s.
So you consider what those guys are doing with this playground work?
A stunt.
Yeah.
I mean the whole thing is built towards
developing these tricks,
right.
To show that like that's incredible.
Yeah.
The,
the ability to hold your legs up like that.
Like folks don't know what kind of core strength that required.
That requires.
Incredible.
Man doing that stripper thing where you're on the pole.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's no joke.
These guys are incredibly fit for that.
They,
they truly,
oh,
that's amazing.
These flags are just like,
wow,
it's so hard to do.
It's really hard to do.
But the torque and the pressure on your shoulders.
Yeah.
Incredible.
Well,
look at you and not bad for an old guy.
Not Bad at all,
quite as high as that guy was,
but amazing that you never did this before.
And I hear you're doing that.
Nah,
I'd never done any of this stuff.
You know,
most,
most of my training was all geared towards,
uh,
trying to make myself a better wrestler and,
or better Jujitsu fighter.
So it's a slightly different energy system and a whole different emphasis with
the workout.
So
that's incredible that these guys have developed a sort of a way to work out on
these playground workouts that has gone worldwide.
I mean,
there's so many of these people that,
oh yeah,
there's the bars,
stars and then there's,
when it was in Australia,
there was the,
uh,
what was it?
The,
uh,
the bar's bese down in Bondai beach,
these Australian guys that well,
you know,
so,
and every country,
especially the poorer countries,
you know,
most of these outdoor playgrounds and gems are pretty available to a lot of
these guys.
Where as they couldn't even afford a regular commercial gym.
Right.
But I was in Russia,
I was really pleasantly surprised.
You could find a pull up bar and dip bar everywhere.
Not for kids,
for adults.
And you'd see people using them.
I mean,
just all over the place like this,
this,
she's doing dip bars and pull up bars and all that kind of stuff.
That's incredible.
Pretty incredible.
Incredible stuff on it.
Yeah.
This is amazing.
This guy's hanging on this other guy.
Some of these guys are crazy strong.
Yeah.
But in a lot of these eastern,
yeah.
All countries that,
you know,
they,
they don't have a lot to do,
you know,
and they're not big guys are looking at us then why really?
But you know,
bodyweight training has a way of kind of,
I mean,
obviously different physique types are going to be attracted to different
activities.
A lot of times people have this mistaken notion that if I do this,
I'm going to look like this.
In reality,
the physique type has success at a particular activity and then stays with
Brian,
for example,
women often like a wants to do dance because they want to look like a dancer,
but if you don't have that proportionate dancers type body to begin with,
you'll never be successful at dance.
Right?
Look,
if you're short and squat and you have big thick legs,
exactly,
Eh,
I don't care how much dance you do,
you're never going to develop the long lean vines of a a dancer.
And the same thing with the urban gymnastics,
you know,
really big boned guys flair,
laying heavy legs,
they're never going to be successful.
That's how activity,
no matter what they do,
is just as,
they wouldn't be able to do what the football player does.
Isn't it also a case for guys that want to compete in MMA,
like those big bulky football player type dudes,
they're never going to be able to have good endurance,
really hard for those guys,
you know,
because I,
they're,
they're kind of like it just naturally fast,
which guys with a well anaerobic endurance levels and no matter how much they
train for endurance,
they're always going to be lacking in that particular department.
You know,
different.
Uh,
the cool thing about combat martial arts though,
uh,
and combat sport,
there's a whole array of physique types of seem to do pretty well.
You have like little fireplug guys at two pretty good who some are Paul Horez
and then tall,
thin wirey kinda guides.
Yeah,
exactly that too.
Wow.
So you find like what's good for your,
you start to develop a style for your particular physique type and all that,
which makes combat martial arts different than any other sport in the planet
because you won't find a big riff is each playing NBA basketball for example.
They're all tall guy.
Occasionally you'll see a little guy but rare.
You only see huge behemoths playing NFL football.
Once in a while you might have some little guy,
but he's like one in millions.
You know what I mean?
They can make it so it's the sport attracts the physique type.
These people are good at it because they had the body that does well with that
particular activity.
It's interesting when you see a guy who was an elite football player or
something like that get into MMA,
their bodies change there.
They slim down,
they become a little little.
There's still big and bulky.
They become a little bit smaller.
We'll,
the guy who's freaked me out the most is Herschel Walker.
That was pretty amazing because he was like 47 or something when he started
finding Ken.
I know,
man.
Yeah,
just Yo Uhg at 47 shredded six pack and just throwing guys around and training
at Aka.
I mean wasn't looking that that's him at like 48 years old fighting in
Strikeforce.
That's pretty remarkable,
isn't it?
What a super athlete that guy was,
wouldn't have been incredible to see him as a 20 something year old competing in
the UFC for sure.
Boy
with his genetic propensity for size and strength and endurance and explosivity,
they would probably wouldn't be drawn to mixed martial arts because of the money
factor.
I don't know,
make like 10 times the money playing NFL football
probably,
but he probably could have made that kind of money.
Look at the fucking sides.
That guy 48 years old,
he could have probably made that kind of money doing anything cause he's so,
he would've been so dominant,
successful at almost any sport.
You're,
you are,
you do have a point there.
How does a guy stay that big look at the size of him at 48 years of age without
lifting weights because that's what he always claimed.
He always claimed it.
Everything he did was body weight.
Do you think that's bullshit?
I,
you know,
I just don't know.
Uh,
I,
I really couldn't that one way or
another.
Uh,
but there's a lot of people have called bullshit on him.
There's no doubt that bodyweight training can make you pretty,
pretty muscular and oh yeah.
Well those bars,
stars guys.
Yeah,
they're really yolked up,
man.
Look at that.
That's him when he was younger.
That's a good picture.
Thank you Jamie.
Perfect picture.
How the fuck does that guy become that other guy?
Show that other picture again.
How the fuck does the other,
those two,
one is the young guy and one's the old guy.
Why?
You'd almost have to start suspecting some type of enhancement there.
Just go back to that other picture.
Jammy.
They'll picture of him.
Swole up and come on son.
One is when he's young and one is when he's 48 and they open a new tab and go
back and forth between the two photos and then may just not build that type of
physique.
I'm sorry.
Well he's doing,
obviously he's doing some sort of body weight conditioning,
strength and conditioning.
There's no doubt that he works really hard.
Yeah,
but the other thing about Herschel Walker,
that's really crazy.
As he said,
he eats like a bowl of soup and a salad every day and that's it.
Ah,
it's hard to hard.
I understand.
Double hard to believe,
but maybe,
I mean fucking,
you know,
I'm the guy that only slept three hours a night.
Who?
Dr Ken Listener.
Look at these two pictures.
Look at that one and then look at the other one.
Jamie,
do you want to do tabs?
You mother fucker too big.
Can you just go back and forth?
Look at that.
What the fuck man?
Jesus,
that's when he's young and here's when he's older.
I'm confused.
I get super confused.
I mean that looks like a guy who probably doesn't actually the way,
how long is he in that picture right there,
young?
1982 that's crazy.
So he would have been something now he might not have been too is true man
strength and so forth at that age.
Didn't want,
he's got some fucking man's drink going on right there Jody though.
And they say,
you know,
go,
he would go to Aka,
he works out with the team,
works out with everybody.
I don't know why he's not doing it anymore.
Well,
maybe he started having some joint problems and they,
you know,
there,
there is a reason why there's a due date and cottage cheese,
you know,
I had a few jobs,
that's a good way of putting it.
You can't,
uh,
you can't out run father time.
He's so big at 48 with no body weight or no a weightlifting.
It seems like to be that big,
you'd have to throw some weights around you would think.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've never seen anyone go to that type of musculature that just did it and I'm
bodyweight training.
But that's not to say that maybe he,
maybe he's an exception to the rule.
You just might be that type of,
uh,
you know,
I had that type of genetics,
you know?
Yeah.
That is the other thing too,
is that some folk,
Larry is doing some body weight exercises.
Looks Damn good.
Even there.
Yeah.
He's,
he's not quite as ripped as he was back in the day,
but he hooks freaking phenomenal dude.
It was a super athlete.
I mean,
that's the thing about football is that they get the big super athletes,
the really big guys,
strong guys,
they get your strongest,
fastest athletes,
pretty much go NFL and this in this country.
I think it makes so much money.
I mean that's just what I mean.
Yeah.
That's where,
that's where the money is.
I mean,
NBA guys are pretty big too,
but they're taller and more ranger,
you know?
But the real power guys are just making him run sprints.
Jesus Christ.
That's not a sprinter with sides of them.
That's a God damn water buffalo.
But for sure,
you know,
I,
I've seen guys build a tremendous physiques just with bodyweight training.
One of my all time favorites was this guy.
What he strode,
he was the black gladiator and the original Spartacus opposite Kirk Douglas.
Oh Wow.
He strode.
He was at spell his last name.
E strode.
He was one of the original body weight trainers and a lot of people don't
realize,
but that fight scene in the original Spartacus with one of the most dangerous
fight scenes ever film,
they actually fought with real weapons and they had trained for three months,
according to Kirk Douglas,
his biography,
they had trained for three months with those weapons in order to put on that
fight scene.
And a strategy has had an a magnificent physique.
That's terrifying.
They use real weapons,
no weapons seen.
Yeah.
And they did the fight and they had rehearsed that magic three months now of
rehearsing and a stroad was uh,
uh,
also a stunt man.
Wow.
And that scene where he jumps up to remember,
he defies the,
the,
the uh,
the Roman patrician,
I don't remember the order.
A Sparty cause his death and a stroad runs up and grabs the wall and pulls
himself up.
He says he's probably the only stunt guy in Hollywood.
They could have pulled that off at that time.
It's like a 10 foot wall.
He jumps up there and grabs it with his fingers and it does like this kind of
like almost like a muscle up.
Like he's trying to get this guy cause he's defying Rome,
you know,
he refuses to kill the character of Spartacus.
Cool movie man.
Kirk Douglas was in pretty good shape back then to correct.
He did his training.
He was trained with what he at the time during the bodyweight journey.
Do you work out a with any other athletes at any other sports besides a,
I'm a May guys.
I know you've uh,
you know,
you've trained quite a few MMA guys.
Diego Sanchez,
he trained him influence only for is Bj Penn fight.
But what about other athletes and other sports?
I've changed a couple NFL guys,
David acres,
they used to be the famous field goal kicker.
He used to come and do Jujitsu with us as well as do some conditioning work.
You have an issue with him where he was kicking with one leg all the time
because,
so he was developing problems.
A,
he,
he had a chronic hamstring pulls on his non kicking leg,
which was his right leg was his non kicking it like he was a left foot kicker.
And uh,
so at my suggestion and I said,
hey,
why not balance yourself out?
You're kicking like 50 kicks a day,
which is a lot of kicks but you're not doing anything for the other side.
So start kicking with the other side and Lo and behold,
hamstring problems disappear.
Well I wanted to ask you about that because I'm getting into archery and I've
got this bow is 90 pounds.
Well that's a pretty hefty about pulling 90 pounds all the time with my right
arm.
Is this a con Pampa with a pulley system?
Yeah.
I should probably get a 90 pound both of my left arm.
What happened to have,
it's just hold the bow and just do some rows,
but yet you can't,
can't grab it with your other hand.
It's the way it's,
I'll show,
I'll show you afterwards.
Get yourself over like a chest expander kept good enough.
What about road?
I've been doing rows,
two rows.
I do 10 or 15 he was one a similar movement pattern.
Right.
Why do it like that?
I do it like this.
So you holding it with your right hand or your left yet?
I hold the boat with my left and I have to pull to the right.
My right.
Okay.
So take a chest or like the old school rubber chest expanders and just start
pulling just to balance yourself out.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know I worked a fairly well known baseball player by the name of David Belt.
I had been working his wife out for a couple of years.
I didn't even realize that she was married to a Philadelphia Philly.
And then one day she says,
Hey man,
Matt husband's having some serious problems and he's in pain a lot and I'd like
you to take a look at them.
So David comes up and ask them,
hey,
how many times a week do you throw a baseball with your right hand?
And he looked at me like thousands of reps and I,
it just,
it just simply said,
what are you doing for your opposite side?
And you'll look at me like,
wow,
I never thought about that.
And I'm thinking,
well for sure baseball,
God,
it has some top trainers.
Right?
What do you think that one of those guys would have figured that out then?
If you have a guy throwed thousands and thousands of balls with your one side,
what did it make sense to do something with your lap?
They don't want to look like a girl.
So with your left,
I gave him one of those little clubs,
you know,
little Indian club.
What's that?
Oh,
we're running at a time.
Oh my gosh.
We did three hours.
Holy Shit.
Look,
go to Maxwell sc doc on how much time we got left?
10 seconds.
It's over.
Uh,
thanks to our sponsor.
That's fucking things over to Steve Maxwell.
You're awesome.
Fantastic fun.
We ran out of time.
See you guys later.
Bye everybody.
For folks that are still listening,
the audio,
uh,
thanks to Tim,
go to rogan.ting.com and save yourself some money.
And also for Steve,
all of June,
he's going to be in Germany.
Frank Foote,
Frankfurt,
Cologne,
Munich,
all of July.
In the UK,
Edinburgh,
London,
Stockport,
Len,
Lancaster's,
Shyer,
Lancashire.
How do you feel that Nika Shot Lancashire?
August 1st,
second and third,
a rev gear,
university rep gear,
university.com,
uh,
presenting Kettlebell and medicine,
Bell Medicine Ball courses,
and uh,
thanks to black belts,
soap.
Um,
that's your,
your buddy's company,
right?
Yeah,
Maui,
blackbelt soap.
Okay.
Uh,
and Maxwell,
sc.com is the website that I've been looking to the whole time that we've been
talking to you.
Fantastic website.
A lot of interesting stuff there,
and people could sign up there and go and get your online course and become one
of the 60 people that,
uh,
you have to handle every day.
God Damn.
It's a lot of people to deal with.
That's awesome though.
Thanks again,
man.
Time flies by.
Let's do it again.
Do it again for sure.
Thanks,
Bill.
All right,
thanks everybody.
We'll see you soon.
The,
uh,
this fucking podcast is over.
Good night.
[inaudible].